welcome back everybody to the
quarterfinals of the bullet chess
championship presented by susquehanna
international group i'm grand master
robert hess alongside me
once again grand master ahman hamilton
amman how you feeling about the bullet
that we're gonna see today
hey robert and what's up everybody well
robert first things first
it's nice that i got a little more sleep
than last time that's all i can say so
we're off to a great start
and if it's uh yesterday was any
indication
i think we're in for some really really
exciting 1v1 matches today
yesterday was really awesome some
matches came down to the very last game
with just seconds remaining
so we are in for a treat for sure and
let's remind everybody of the format
because for those who are not here
yesterday you may not be used to it
we had a whole swiss then a
knockout just to get to this point 12
people were in the
championship bracket and it is a time
control of
one minute with zero increments so if
you are down to three seconds
that's all you have to play your game of
chess you better be quick
you better have the mouse speed because
if you don't you're going to lose on
time and we are
seeing here that there are going to be
matches of
30 minutes in length but let's remind
everyone of the prize fund because
first place is a cool 10k not bad even
for the losers of today's match mod
500 yeah that's not bad at all robert
for uh
for something that you could probably
catch me doing for 12 hours unpaid
hey not going to complain about a couple
hours paid
absolutely so what the players love to
do regardless and who are those players
well we have
our quarterfinal pairings uh that we're
going to start with andrew tang
against nihal sarin andrew taking the
three seed nehaldi
sixth hikari nakamura takes on arjun
erigazi who defeated lavon ironian
in that final game with just like one
second on his clock so that was a really
exciting matchup
and then i think the one that will be
the most even
alireza farouza taking on vladislav
artemyev
that is the super grand master matchup
of the day
taking place in our third match and well
it's the quarterfinals there should be
four matchups
amman eric won yesterday but he's not
here today
yeah we have a lot of exciting matches
there you touched on you know four
against five i mean
the the seating indicates that is going
to be probably the most exciting match
of the day
obviously hikaru the favorite in his
match will still be exciting to see how
arjun fares but of course
you definitely have player like icaru as
the favorite no matter what
and eric supposed to be here playing his
match today but
had to back out at the last minute
robert such is
uh such is the way he uh he tried his
best to qualify ended up
coming in as a replacement but
ultimately won't continue in
in the tournament well it's unfortunate
but i think one person who will not be
too upset about that is
donya naraditsky because dania he would
have been the favorite at least on paper
anyway
he makes his way through to the
semi-finals that wouldn't be surprising
regardless but it's unfortunate
because eric of course is a very great
bullet player would have had chances but
we are starting
with over-the-board action soon it will
be andrew tang
taking on nihal sarin it is the penguin
gm
taking on the indian teenage superstar
and
we would be remiss not to give a big
shout out to our presenting partner for
the bullet chess championship
susquehanna
international group is sponsoring this
event it's
their global quantitative trade
quantitative trading firm
that use strategic games like chess to
improve their decision-making skills
and won the largest proprietary trading
firms in the
world so thank you to sig for making
this happen
and hey we are about to take off we're
just
a few minutes away here from the action
i'm really excited for it because this
matchup between
the penguin gm and nihal sarin who do
you think's the favorite you knew i was
gonna put you on the spot
i was ready for this well first of all i
saw andrew warming up on chess.com
like just minutes before their match so
i feel like andrew is totally in bullet
mode
um i i haven't seen uh andrew's games
you know because
i don't think he played that many of the
qualifiers if he did at all
um and nihal we've been exposed to a lot
lately we saw
you know his journey here um how he got
here tang
amazing amazing player um i think that
he's probably
played a lot less games on chess.com
something to think about
um uh just in terms of what he's used to
and
nihal i've said it before one of the
easiest players to underestimate in this
event robert
he has a really good style for bullet um
he doesn't feels like he doesn't make
full piece blunders or checkmate
blenders very often
so it's just such a good style but
ultimately who do i think is going to
squeak it out i gotta go with my boy
andrew tang on this one
well it's the reason why he doesn't
blunder pieces is because when he
actually drops them his opponents
resigned remember that game
yesterday against alexander bortnick
where
he mouse slipped nihal mouse slipped and
instead of winning that piece
bourdain resigned he'd already pre-moved
that resignation in his head
but of course nihal was up about four
games down the stretch losing the
final three so it became a close match
even though earlier on it wasn't
and so for neal he said afterwards he
had a very professional response you're
saying i need to fix my mistakes i can't
afford to lose three games in a row
especially not against somebody like
andrew tang yep
no you you make a great point there and
andrew's the type of guy that
you give a one two three game lead he's
gonna run away with the match
robert it's as simple as that as we see
the the players there
andrew is that where is he wearing a c9
uh
jersey there i can't tell i can't tell
either but i wouldn't be surprised
putting his esports or representing them
well
and he always is doing a great job when
it comes to bullet chest the blindfold
bullet the blindfold hyper bullet you
name it
he does it well but he will have his
hands full today against nihal son i
like what you said
that i think it's easy to underestimate
nihal just because of
his kind of quieter style he's not the
type of player who's going in for those
crazy attacks
to try to defeat you on the board
immediately in addition to put you in
time travel he plays very principled
chess through and through
exactly like i i feel like when i'm
watching him i'm never sure whether i'm
actually watching like a
time scramble or a classical game like
it always feels so pure and
that's uh it's kind of rare to come
across in bullet whereas
andrew obviously tremendous player but
definitely a little more skewed towards
the speed
side of things which is an extremely
effective bullet strategy
and you know with the 30-minute timer
and they get a half-time break
15 minutes in i wonder how that kind of
match format will
benefit which player because sometimes
you go for hours playing against the
same opponent
other times you just play a short match
but now that you know that you have a
time limit it's not just we'll agree to
stop at some point
i wonder which of these two players both
of whom are very experienced
despite their young age i wonder who
that's going to play to their favor
exactly i mean we have uh we have a
match about the kids here it's no longer
the the kids taking down the old guard
robert we got
uh andrew tang who's renowned for his
speed and you know what he can do in a
time scramble
against nihal sarin and we've seen nihal
prove himself
obviously thus far robert in order to
even be here in this match so it should
be really exciting
it should be for sure and we're just a
couple minutes away the players are
getting set it seems that
uh just trying to make sure everything
is smooth on their ends we don't want
any
technology issues any lag or
things of the sort but it seems like we
are just about to be ready
and i made you choose the predict the
winner
i haven't chosen one myself i'm gonna go
with nihal
i like to style yesterday i think that
he
was very stoic throughout the match and
andrew tang i will
acknowledge is the favorite if there was
a betting market for this
tang should be the favorite but i'm
gonna go with nihal based on yesterday's
match
i don't know i get the sense that he's
really ready to play
yeah and i mean what did we hear in the
interview yesterday robert he was
talking about how
he doesn't mind playing a bit later uh
in the day
that internet's better he likes playing
bullet at night
so i mean aren't we playing even later
than yesterday and maybe he's just
getting better and better
that's true the later he gets the better
he plays and well
he may be past midnight he's wide awake
ready to go
and he's looking serious the action is
just taking off now
andrew tan gets the white piece oh my
gosh i did not know his rating was 33.65
the only reason i knew that is i was
actually watching a farouja stream where
he was like trying to get the highest
rating on the website and it's like oh
man i didn't even notice
andrew is up here at 33.65 what the hell
is he doing up there
he's got a match tomorrow and look at
that he's still grinding the elo
wow well good start to this game andrew
also has that very positional style
especially on the white side these
london systems b7 pawn cannot be
captured without dropping b2
that's why the queen dropped back to c2
and then d2 so both sides
very solid here is andrew about to go
queenish for knight g5 and checkmate his
opponent
uh yes first of all queen h4 knight g5
is incredibly scary and on top of that
even a bishop takes knight rook e3 to h3
is gonna follow wow and look at that
knight d6 retreat in the knight to e5 so
look at knight f5 no rookie three rook
h3 mate for you
if you take on f56 the epawn and he's
trying to
keep that h5 closed as long as possible
yeah but well you say no rookie three
rook h3 for you that's why he took that
knight on f5
he's renewing the threat how do you even
stop this rook h3 knight h5 he has that
pawn f5 stopping g4
and look at nihal just grabbing that
pawn fearless and andrew's down
10 seconds yeah okay he wants the knight
on g5 now
he's i think the knight should have gone
there in the first place oh yeah he's
just indecisive
back and forth yeah that's not going to
do the trick you can't just go back and
forth at night you're down a pawn
and i think that blacks when you charge
exactly this a5 a4 a3
and keep in mind h3 means you're
admitting you're no longer going for
that plan and rook takes a3 queen d1
that's a beautiful move queen c1 played
eight takes b2 queen between queen takes
c3
black is just trading off pieces and
only up one pawn is a double pawn so
shouldn't be that impressive for black
but no time for white
we say no time for white but this is
andrew we're talking about f4
to follow should be the end of the game
i reckon rook f1
checkmate coming and that's a
resignation and it's kind of funny
because
white looked ready to check me with the
rooks in the seventh rank and yet that
knight on g3 configuration with the rook
on the first rank that's deadly one
nothing in nihal's favor
and look at this another extremely solid
start to the game
yeah and we we actually have i was
wondering whether it was going to be a
zooka tour of bishop on b2 but no it's
actually more of a cauli system
where you play e4 h3 and although your
bishop's trap
eventually that bishop comes out after
moves like knight b3
and wait a nice trapped on h5 so there's
knight g3 but he moves the bishop first
because i guess that bishop was hanging
rookie wants a knight g3
that was a fork that was available to
black yeah now f6 busting the position
wide open there's going to be some
sacrifices like if you go
and trap this knight or go for it there
might be f takes e5 and
e4 after that so instead the positional
choice by white trying to play against
his e6 pawn the knight on h5
i think we'll see a bunch of trades in
the e5 square no knight f4 first but
that allows it take
and then can you take on d7 and take on
e6 what is happening here
wow and so many things are getting
treated right now that it looks like
what's gonna end
up happening is oh wow queen
nope that's not what i was gonna say
robert no he decides to go aggressive
because the queen on c7 in line with
that bishop
he takes on d7 if queen for his knight
takes f6 check so i guess he trades
everything that we thought would be
traded just in a completely different
move order
yeah i did not expect that at all but uh
it looks totally reasonable everything
gets traded
tripling on the f file now in f3 offhand
this looks really good for white just
because the pawn that black's attacking
look at this pawn structure c3 f3 is so
easy to defend and black is now totally
passive
and white has the better king also has
more time and look at this king h1 move
just moving off the diagonal so there's
no queen trade
queen comes to a7 that queen is a little
bit iffy out there but
you can't trap it i was gonna say i like
the move rook to b6 it's just one of
those annoying moves in bullets like
wait a minute
all of a sudden he has to play a4a5
because he might be a little scared
about trapping his queen
oh but look at that rook on g6 pin
that's really good by andrew to quickly
get the king back from g8
and it's a three second lead for nihal
but he blundered the pawn on the a file
yep but this is all about speed andrew
started to to ramp up the speed and so
did nihal
oh that king's in big trouble there was
a rook h8 check that was available there
and h4 for black to stop h4 for white
oh my gosh we'll get jake queen d8 just
go for the mate oh he doesn't do it
he he wants the solid free moves and at
this point
it's looking like uh it's looking like
nihal's the favorite but tang is so
damn quick he's gonna get a drop yeah
he's forced to draw he doesn't want one
though he realizes he can win on time
oh that was amazing mouse speed by
andrew tang
that was absolutely unbelievable that
was so
so impressive so what you do is you you
sort of repeat the draw for
one or two moves and you evaluate just
what the time is that gives you time
while you're pre-moving to check the
clock he did that he saw it was like
whoa about one second one and a half a
piece
i know when i'm gonna stop taking this
draw and play make another pre-move
executed perfectly and that wasn't a
dirty flag that was a skilled flag right
there
you got to give him huge credit for that
and as we see on screen nihal actually
beat andrew tang in the jscc
event in 2020 so nihal won that event
that involved
five minute and three minute and then
the one minute with a one second
increment so a different time control
altogether and well nihal now one to one
and that knight on d6 looks pinned and
looks like a problem for white yeah i
was gonna say knight b4 and just the
king is
is all of a sudden in trouble there's
queen h6 ideas for white but
what's the follow-up i don't see it just
one check the king slides to g8 and then
knight on d6
is still pinned white is down upon and
nihal's up
10 plus seconds maybe knight takes e4
but
it's just it feels like rook takes d1
and and pieces get over there way too
quickly
yeah and here knight d4 i'm shutting
down the d bomb i'm showing on the
bishop
the knight gets to c4 good for you oh my
gosh knight b3 check is rook d1 queen
b32 wow
that was unbelievable what attack did he
does that worked there it's got to be
takes takes knight h3
oh but then you're down i mean the only
good thing for white is that king on
jake
entombs the is on rook queenie too oh
gosh bishop f8 just kick that queen out
of there
and then you can move your knight to d5
now the the only thing about this
position it's so funny it's like my it
was minus eight minus nine there
but that rook on h8 means i think this
is still a game for white to play 17
seconds ticking down for nihal
so queen e6 the safe move and trying to
trade queens but
all right his king is oh bonus queen
that's game
totally forgot it's like it's almost
like when when would queen be a
check uh checking a king on g8 uncover
a rook on h8 right that probably threw
him off
it's true we're used to studying
tactical patterns
but not that one where the king moves
off from g8 and there's a rook on h8
to win a queen that's unusual but right
now we go back to this college system
very calm start of the game for both
sides here will that knight go to h5
again the answer
looks like it's going to be s um yeah
and i wonder if he's just going to
follow up with some g6
because when you move the rook to d8 i
feel like f6 makes uh much less sense
and there's some bishop h7 check knight
g5 yeah knight g5
or not anymore to start yeah well okay
actually you're right knight g5 there
was a possibility he didn't play it
though and
what's going to happen you could take on
c6 take on f6 the g
pawn will take back and f6 i guess and
it seems like black's position is flimsy
yeah well i'd like this though for black
b takes and here
i mean i think almost any piece can take
back and
well knight takes e5 square robert
that's where all the pieces are going oh
and black could have played e5 because
the tactics on the f2 square
unfortunately after this move sequence
white is controlling the e5 square
yeah this is tough because you need some
sort of like
knight e4 move or something but no nihal
is in full
mount here as they say in mma and uh
everything's under control look at the
time as well this is not looking good
no white's pieces are perfect that
bishop one d7 not helping out even if
you trade the dark square bishops the e6
pawn is the permanent problem
and look at nihal with the rook left
queen e3 maybe queen h6 and queen g5
just don't hang that rook on e1 and he
moves his work out the way
yeah not only to make sure it's not
hanging but also watching the d-pawn in
case uh he
wanted to move his queen is nihal faster
than tang because he's again
up 12 seconds well the thing is nihal
plays like i don't think he's faster
than him mouse speed wise and in a time
scramble but nihal plays
his regular bullet game chess faster
than like anyone
yeah i mean he is ridiculously fast here
and he's going to win on time in this
game
this queen upon end game you could
potentially win this not very easy to do
but i think he's just going to win the
clock
yeah this is this is what we call dead
lost in a in the bullet sense you know
although you say that now and watch tank
somehow survive this
there's just no way i i couldn't believe
it
i couldn't believe it he's doing really
well but he's not going to get away 25
check nice
interposing with a check to the black
king and that's a win for knee hall and
he goes up three to one
yeah and andrew's back to this and i'm
not sure like what this is by the way
it's an interesting
london line that they they're both going
right back into the last time it
happened
was this and i mean you can see the
evaluation bar doesn't really like
white's position so what else does
andrew have here
that we didn't see last time i think
this is not going to go well a second
time in a row this i mean we see the
eval bar it's just clearly in black's
favor
and i'm wondering if andrew prepared
some lines in this or he just keeps
going to it
because he hasn't had the break yet to
look into the openings well
believe me that's gonna be the first
thing he looks at in the break he's
gonna be like wait a minute
probably he didn't prepare this line for
this match but he sort of has it
prepared
in general for the london and i mean
we're just looking at position that's
like minus five
or more this is unacceptable and this
whole knight b3 check we just saw this
happen the same game
yeah why would you repeat this if you're
tang
nihal must be so confused so he wants to
play the same game but he's not gonna
blunder his queen on b8 this time this
is some big brain
strategy as well he moved his queen back
to f4 earlier so king g7 is possible
like you could just bring your king out
of rook d8 and try to check me with
queen b1
maybe g4 g5 but but d8 happens from
there's some 94 queen bee one made ideas
nah this this is just gross
move like e3 robert no no no no no
queen b1 94 bishop g5 is that the
takes on c3 wow that's simple and then
his king's out
king said wow i don't know e3 was was
gross well that was a beautiful move and
he just like you said he just wants to
bring the rook out nothing special
no and queen b2 and now rook to d8 and
look who's king is on the back rank now
the first rank
yeah the the white rook on each one is
the one trapped no i think
rook d2 bishop d4 this is
too straightforward an amazing game
four to one in nihal's favor and
tank needs to change that opening if i'm
andrew tank's friends i know some of you
are watching right now
send that guy a text that he should look
at during the break right now
to change that opening yeah there's i
mean you're not a real friend if you're
not messaging him to change that opening
immediately robert
yeah you you better help him out here
because he cannot repeat that anymore
it's just not going his way
yeah and i i have felt that these lines
these kali system lines
have been the best chance for andrew um
so sort of like i feel like nihal's come
out on top and credit to him but
uh when you compare them to the rest of
the openings that andrew's getting these
are definitely preferable
and look at niagara and queen b7 trading
the queens and the pawn on a6
such a thorn in black side because that
pawn a7 will forever
be a target and andrew doing really well
with the tactics here but bishop d6
the rook on f8 is trapped you'll give up
e1 and you have this knight against a
bishop
oh this looks painful look at that
knight on b5
so strong you can always take on a7 that
night's a stallion
and you could play rook d1 you can't go
king eight cause knight c7 so rook's
coming to d7
you're winning the a7 pawn and that's
clean yeah which is why he played rook
there he wants rook a8 and king
just knight b5 a7 and you're going to
get a queen this is actually yeah
he wants bishop c5 and you know some
sort of pressure on f2 but it's just not
enough
no you can't even take this knight
because the pawn queens so d4 to a4
that is classy as class he gets no i'm
telling you like the
the accuracy that nihal can show in a
bullet game
is unprecedented like this is uh this is
incredible bullet chest right now it
really is something here this is a
better way
for andrew to play aggressively he's not
giving up a pawn he's not getting too
wild
but g4 already puts nihal in the think
tank and look at these pawns go forward
yep yep no nihil has a has a
very very good style for this and bishop
d3 not even going for g6
this is a i mean this is an attack
robert i think this could be good for
andrew
i like it queen e2 and castle queen said
if he wants not now because e5 is under
threat three different times
but with the peace trades it feels
harder for white to launch that attack
although a timely h6 will be a problem
for black
right yeah queen g5 so he's he's sort of
saying look i'll trade the queens and it
won't attack you but only if you fix my
pawns
right and white's up a pawn to begin
with so i really like the way andrew
plays king is safe and sound on e2
with a phalanx of third-ranked pawns in
front of it and he's going to trip on
the g-file
yeah b3 nice and solid a4 can always be
taken by that rook
keep in mind that rook on g4 patrolling
the fourth rank
well so much so that it's just going to
a4 itself
and the question is what to do with this
knight on d2 you'd really like to
bring it forward to help out your attack
but i guess the pawns are fixed
this is looking very promising rook five
will hit the d5 pawn at any moment
he just takes the pawn a4 and there's
gonna be rook a8 though
um wow look at him use this fourth rank
completely unexpected that the rooks
would be heroes in the fourth rank not
in the g file
yes oh my gosh the king of three
yeah how do you not play king f3 but
yeah this is this is uh very solid
a2 falls king f3 but i think andrew with
the time edge and a very
finally a very well played game by
andrew start to finish
he is going to take this win it looks
like and i wonder if nihal's already
getting that territory of just wasting
match clock
you know we haven't even hit the halfway
point but he's up five to one then you
start thinking i'm winning so i might as
well
let the time go off right and don't
blame him that's just good strategy rook
d4
and he is going to let that one go with
3.7 seconds left and andrew bleeding a
bit of raiding here but
that's the last thing he's thinking
about is he needs to get back in this
match
and uh i think this is going to be the
final game before the break robert
it will indeed and we talk about this
every day that the ratings going into
the match not so important they
fluctuate all the time 200 points up 200
points down well maybe not 200 points
out for android 10 that would be 3 500
plus but you get the point that in a
given day you can just drop all these
rating points so nihal
might be underrated today in fact and we
get this position very solid approach
from knee hall
even in terms of the pieces but extra
pawn for white on the queen side extra
pawn for black in the center
yeah this is uh this is definitely a
solid position
for both sides but especially if you're
andrew the way that mash has been going
can't complain here he's getting active
and he's got you know the
the queen side pawns fixed and nice move
f5 so there's no
queen trades on the diagonal queen comes
back to e4
white is very passive here i would try
to play with like queen c2 at some point
and trade those queens but then there
was knight d3 at the end after the queen
trade so
this is looking promising for andrew i
like the way he's probing here he's
making weaknesses that's c3 pawn now
target queen a2 on the cards and can you
he's not saying a3 because he doesn't
want to drop his e5 pawn that one is
essential to keep a better position here
h5 now all of a sudden white's pieces
are going forward knight d3 is a
possibility
and andrew is up on the clock though
yeah i was going to say the way that
andrew had been playing those last 10
moves or so with the queen shuffling
was he was playing like a guy who didn't
mind playing a slightly inaccurate move
because he knew that he was gaining a
little bit on the clock every time oh
queen c4 check was missed and say takes
an a7 and b6
so white's king's in danger but what has
all those past pawns on the queen side
queen b said don't take money forward
with the queen because then there's
knight gta check with mate
knight g3 is made no matter what if that
happens by the way i
i'm surprised there's even a way out
here thank you three maiden one oh
e3 oh queen f2 mate coming yeah and now
queen h1 queen g2 and the queen d2 check
and you win the night with check
beautiful and just e2 e1 also is uh
would have done the trick but this uh
feels pretty nice for andrew
on the clock as well uh and lots of
pawns on the queen side so no stalemate
yeah because here you would sack that
queen immediately exactly
wow the game is over that means we are
heading towards
halftime this game will be canceled as
soon as it begins
and if you're nihal right you were told
going into the
match at the halfway point you would be
up five to three you'd be ecstatic
but how are you feeling now that you
were up five to one and you just dropped
two games in a row
and convincingly at that well i think
you're feeling good that there's a break
robert
that couldn't be uh better times because
we saw andrew tang was starting to go
on a streak so just that that little
mental
uh break that lapse between games i
think is gonna help him a lot
however if you're andrew you're
definitely feeling good even though
there's a break
you still feel that momentum and now
after a couple wins
you're telling yourself okay this is a
guy i can beat i've done it twice now
in a row let's keep this momentum and
speaking of
breaks for the players we're going to
take one as well all of you out there
take your break too because you will not
want to miss any of the action
go grab yourself a snack some water
whatever may be we'll be back shortly
for more from the bullet chest
championship presented by sig
i got into playing poker in college and
really liked it but
never considered i could make a career
out of it until jeffy ass came and gave
a talk at harvard
jeff explained that yes you can actually
use gaming skills for your career and
for something to do on a day-to-day
basis
which was exciting at the time i thought
it was really cool we can pretty much
guarantee you that we will give you the
best education you will be taught
all that we know in a very professional
manner by expert teachers
and you're going to be mentored and i
like to think that there's no other
place where you can get as much
mentorship as you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common
is a sense of competitiveness and
interest in
in gaming and strategy in general i
would say you're
you're playing a game as a career it's
very satisfying to me
that we've been able to employ so many
people give them not just an opportunity
to make a lot of money but to be with
the smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun and make a lot
of friends and create a culture
of reason
[Music]
and we return here ready for the second
half of the match andrew tang faces a
5-3 deficit he will try to work his way
back he's won two games in a row
and amman during the break we were
informed that the players
ended their screen share with one
another which is to help ensure fair
play
because they want to analyze their games
and see their mistakes
yeah that's that's hilarious like you're
you're in a call with your opponent and
you're about to
go in and analyze maybe andrew was going
to check that line that you and i were
talking about and he's like wait a
minute
neil can see this okay and then they
both ended up closing their screen share
checking the lines and then obviously
turning it back on so they can play the
and it goes to show how seriously
they're taking this and honestly the
chest component a lot of people think
that bullet only is about the mouse
speed
well if you're not getting good
positions early on oftentimes it doesn't
matter how quick your mouse is because
you are not
going to have a good position not good
enough to withstand the pressure to get
to the time scramble so andrew
probably looking at that white opening
nihal his opens have been solid
not spectacular just that solid approach
game after game
and it's working wonders for him and uh
it's
it's pretty surprising that um he went
for that line
again that's what i just don't
understand like it didn't work the first
time but he repeated it so if we see
that one again i mean we might have to
do some real uh
talking to him behind the scenes but
let's see if he switches it up
yeah we're getting away from this a lot
of this knight e5 g4 i think it's a much
better plan for him
and nihal seems ready for it though yeah
this is this is something that they
played last time it did work out for
andrew
so i i wouldn't be surprised if he
repeats things
yeah and nihon went knight to d7 and
eventually andrew took this pawn to h5
so he it still similar said giving upon
a c6 but not caring i guess because
white's king is in the center
yeah and he's a little exposed on the
king's side i think from a positional
standpoint if you take on h5 knight
takes h5 feels pretty good
and knight on h7 i don't like the look
of that piece of rookie eight knight to
f8 things like that
so knight can get back in the game that
h4 pawn just like the h5 pawn could
become a problem
yeah well first of all i was gonna say
that h pawn could have been taken but he
decided to avoid it knight g6 king g3
e5 e5 i would have put e5 without even
thinking about it
but now he plays it queen g4 check is
happening and you have to be careful
about this
and the reason he played knight e7 was
because e5 f5 he didn't want things to
be closed down
um wow look at this queen behind enemy
lines but i can't do anything like
because queen e2 and how many pawns is
white up
there's also like you know close to a
draw with like rick g3
rook g1 in case andrew's interested in
something like that
he doesn't seem that interesting he
wants to play for more and i like the
move from nihal i didn't like how much
time it took
to play knight g6 he's keeping the
action alive the king's on f2 not that
safe
but white is up several pawns c5 and now
speaking of those several pawns they're
starting to connect f5 is a threat
f5 played and lucky that he had that
queen takes a2
but unfortunately it actually helps
white the time scramble why is the head
in the clock
oh g g takes f6 is a free pawn now it's
not
now instead of playing g6 which was like
looking a lot stronger
so i would say a little bit shaky there
from tang but should absolutely still be
a win
yeah c7 next and you're gonna queen
there's no way to stop it
yep so tang wins three in a row picking
up where he left off and
in case you thought this was going to be
a blowout uh guess again because this is
only one point lead now out of nowhere
and now you neon needs that kind of
solid game that
scores them some points that's what i
was always told if you're losing several
games in a row you just want to stop the
bleeding get at least a half point here
and there's no way to ensure that in
bulges isn't classical you can't just
force pieces off get into an end game
make a draw no you need to play
yeah and you need to play quick
sometimes when you're trying to play for
a draw and bullet too much you end up
playing slowly and just get flagged
exactly and i like white pieces but no
real advantage right now you see the
eval bar says they're
extremely level and one of the bishop
takes f3 coming you have to watch out
for that because that would ruin your
pawn structure
yeah i was gonna say wasn't that
possible in the previous
previous turn that seems like a kind of
a big mess i agree with you there and so
we're seeing a trait of knights queen d3
will be the response to rook c4 that's
why i went rogue d5
and double pawns but they're not weak
and you know bishop e4 now rookie e5
would be the response with a pin
very interesting game right now and
maybe just bring the rook back to
d5 i think he was concerned about bishop
e4 but i don't love the move really
quick oh no backrank checkmate and
andrew just shakes his head
the bishop on c2 is a sniper covering
the escape square and he sees those
i mean basically put it this way he
doesn't miss those no
no and what i
keep forgetting who's white who's black
because they're playing sort of similar
openings
with both colors yeah i was going to say
the same thing when i saw that a pawn i
was like oh here comes nihal with the
fondant a6
oh wait a minute nope all the way around
and we have nine minutes 40 seconds
remaining plenty of time for this
comeback
but if i'm andrew you know you need to
continue playing the way you've been
playing even though you just lost that
game that was a one move blunder
whereas in the previous games he was out
playing the all
yep and this is a very specific setup
that black sometimes goes for
f5 with knight and g6 supporting the
knight on f4 and it's tough to move
these pieces
and queen wow d5 what a shot there
and he can take on d5 trade queens take
on d6 the end of this variation if he
wants but instead he keeps the queens on
the board
which i think actually helps black i
thought he was going to take the queen
and play bishop takes f5 but
uh instead queen e2 and all of a sudden
this
felt like it worked out for black
although knight e5 is not what i
expected wow
no that's a pin and if knight takes f3 g
takes f3 maybe there's a counter attack
down the g file real quick love that
move queen c7
i really like that move taking a step
back d5 shutting the bishop down and hey
don't mind if i do threaten mate in two
and that was clearly seen by andrew but
he's down 10 seconds once again
neha outplaying him and much faster than
the clock
takes d5 rook takes e5 ooh it has to be
with the rook yet and the rook slides to
e5 so tang
sort of uh surviving the tactical
skirmish but what about the clock
seven seconds and he takes a d fun king
h8 okay giving it rook takes e6
so that's the time that's what's of the
utmost importance here
yep he needs to start you know showing
us those tang free moves
he's gonna need them and knight takes
some bishop d5 watch out for backrank
mate similar to what we just saw
happen to tank he's trying to use that
to his advantage
oh my gosh i covered the c8 square
that's check
oh and queen d8 covers the background
and attack the bishop no two seconds
left yeah
there's no way this would be too insane
he can try to get rid of these uh
these pawns over here but that pawn on
b6 guess what
stay in there the rest of the game oh my
gosh this game's still going
how is he doing this what what moves my
knee haul in the time trouble
wow i'm i'm so surprised by the move
knight e5
tang must have been as well normally
you'd think to flag that you just bring
your king over
but he goes 95 knight c4 guarding the
pawn again predicting
bishop d7 from andrew wow that was
one way to win on time and there are
seven minutes
20 seconds remaining andrew starting to
run out of time he needs to win this
game
yeah i think there's there's no question
bishop takes f3 finally this move gets
played
that has been available a lot in this
match i want to say
and and look at look at the position now
and this looks like you're playing for
two results
if you're black but in bullet it's
really playing for one it feels like
you're
so much easier to play you're upon ahead
that pawn d4 is isolated and weak
this seems too easy for a player of
andrew's caliber
it does it does um and he's he just
needs to solve this rook
issue like if he gets this rook on h4
kind of back to civilization
i think he's got this bishop g5 and game
over oh knight d6
oh that's one tactic you want to avoid
with these 96 tactics
that would be pretty funny i guess brook
takes that f4 bishop g5 simplifying
would
would be easy as well but um i'm not
sure if he's doing this the right way
probably rook takes f4 bishop g5 now is
the idea yeah i think
you have to keep i'll just bishop g5 now
because they've known these tactics and
the rook on d2 behind that knight is
just he's wasting time i think is what
nihal's doing
and he can yeah i mean not even he can't
play e5
maybe he's not wasting time maybe he's
just trying to survive this yeah maybe
he's just doing well
wow how is he only down upon the rook
end game
i don't know that's incredible yeah this
is really just
wild stuff but the problem is oh and now
you take on a4 so that would have
theoretically
entered into drosh territory but not
when you're down eight seconds in bullet
yeah but that was a good move rook f
rook d to f6
so strong yeah now you're up two pawns
this is winning
for black and with the time that's the
easiest part about it
yep he always has king up to g4 ideas
and king takes h4 and that will be
enough now he's got the two pawns
and i wonder if both players almost
studied this so that they can win by
pre-move
rook takes h5 there yep one opportunity
missed but he still would have been able
to build a bridge and
yeah nice last try by nihol he let the
time run out oh no he resigned with
point three left but either way he
should be spending that time i feel like
yeah yeah those those
.2 milliseconds robert gonna come back
to bite him i'm sure
it is amazing that nihal even got that
far in that game he looks
completely lost i would have been
hanging pieces you know
uh well well before absolutely
wow okay so we get a castle there's
stuff happening in the d file but i
guess the knight f6 covers d7 so it's
safe for now rook c1 is the immediate
idea but h
no you can't play h4 for black so what
was that move
h5 is just like a just supposed to scare
you and it's kind of working yeah i was
scared and i was like wait you can't
play h4 so what's what's the deal here
oh bishop takes g3 is on the cards yeah
i like the look of that
yeah just take it no okay he doesn't
and now knight takes h5 so he left it
too long bishop takes g3 was just very
strong there g2
and e3 hanging after that yeah that
would have been a clean extra pawn for
black
it almost looks like what h5 was
designed to do make you play h3 and then
drop something
and neil looks confused i was just
looking at his face over there he's like
what's going on like queen g4
wait quincy foreign made on g7 just that
that looks pretty strong look at that
bishop on g
uh b2 rather like i'm looking to get the
queen out there
well he plays it i don't know
what was different about the move order
but i guess knight 66 is going to win
material regardless
and g6 is the only move that's the big
brain stuff
yeah too much for me oh knight of six
check
98 98 double check winning the queen
nasty stuff from andrew who's finding
his form when he needs to
he missed 97 queenie tour was a force
mate but this is still obviously winning
the problem though is it spend some time
three minutes 30 seconds remaining
this will be a one point match that
i don't think the time is costly just
yet but that could have been some
valuable time
and he made some money yeah now he's got
me
one point match one point match andrew
tang with an epic comeback
can he continue this and actually take
this match nihal
again playing the solid kali system and
remember if there's a draw
still technically okay for tank they
will get another game for sure
so if you're andrew i don't think you
have to go all out as if this is a
must-win game
i agree with you there and right now
white claiming space with c5 for andrew
right now
taking the space right back and isolated
pawn we
exactly i think you have to start by
taking on d4
um it goes e5 oh that's knight f3
and i'm not sure this is what you want a
position you want to be and he
keeps the bishop though robert i like
that decision yeah but strategically
this is
not what black wanted that bishop one f6
is a bad piece normally we like the
bishop pair
but not here when the bishop is stuck
protecting the e5 pawn
94 threatens 96 oh oh queen 7 in 96
ooh and that's a tactic he's not gonna
miss and oh place knight d6 first so
he's tried to do the same tactic but
maybe in the wrong way
and now he blows his piece the knight's
pinned and
he did that andrew tang did this the
lean back in the chair
he knows that this is his game to win
and he might even be able to complete
the comeback in regular time robert
that would be unreal and right now
they're under two minutes remaining
so if you need to keep your eye on the
match clock because whoever
is losing the next game you might just
resign like just give up because
if this goes the distance there is no
time remaining
so nihal i know he's lost a lot of games
recently he needs to gather his
composure if you're andrew tank keep
doing what you're doing because it's
working
and speaking of doing what you're doing
he has got a position we haven't seen so
far
and honestly i've i've seen this in
action and it can be
it can be pretty nasty with the attack
yeah because queen h5 ideas there's even
rook takes h7 queen h5 to consider
but don't play it just yet here comes
that second knight and it's a clogged
middle of the board of mine
yeah look at i mean positions like this
you i start to wonder about the move g4
and there it is on the board i mean this
is the only way to continue the attack
and there's a minute 15 remaining and
this looks terrible for black and we see
the eval bar
skyrocketing in andrew's favor you
should consider resigning
at some point bishop takes e4 knight
takes h6
g3 all this stuff must win yeah queen
how do you stop the mate on each eight
uh
you can't there's no way you gotta
resign
how's gotta resign this game he smartly
resigns he has time for one more game
yep so now it's it's knee hell that
needs to make the comeback
and andrew i mean is he going to be able
to all he needs is a draw robert in this
game right here
he does and he helped playing the same
exact so we said andrew's friend should
call him
maybe nihal needed some advice from
friends to stop playing this opening
it's not like he's getting bad positions
it's just right hasn't been working out
for
him yeah it's just uh i think he got a
win in it early on
give him some confidence there andrew
fixed that up and since then i think
he's been totally fine for him
and we have this pawn he something about
this pawn structure
he likes well not the isolated pumbaa
until that point with the extra pawn on
the queen side
now he's playing for the activity rook
c6 as possible queen d5 always will
trade queens
how could this be i love this for andrew
yeah how could this be what you want for
nihal
i think he's just tilt like his mind
he's sending it he's sending it it's
unacceptable
queen d1 and rook back to d6 tr i would
trade those queens rook d6 and just
you know hold the position he's trying
to go queenie one rook d one it made or
not he's just playing solidly right now
yeah i thought i thought your idea
looked great there
so rook c7 played no more and look at
this he's getting too passive
andrew knows he needs to hold to win the
match and now he's getting all passive
in the position
yeah he had opportunities to trade
queens or to go for maid
none of it happened okay can you go back
to e4 because you don't want to make a
drop you can't play bishop
wait isn't this a drawing repetition is
this the draw and time's up he just lost
the match
oh my gosh he lost the match on a
repetition
is that right uh that is a hundred
percent correct as far as
oh and you can see he just he's in
disbelief he didn't
know i couldn't keep an eye on the match
clock and the game at the same time he
just
is he can't believe it he's bewildered
how could that match slip
out of his grasp he was up five to one
but andrew tang said slow and steady
wins the race and
he came back with storming and wins
steady and bullet robert
well no he's fast and aggressive he's
really not slow or steady but either way
he wins the match amman what did we just
see there
you know what we saw something i think
that i i mentioned during
um previous matches which is that um the
favorite and you know on paper i think
we'd have to agree with andrew coming
into the match
i feel like the favorite takes time to
warm up you know to get the the gears
flowing
and i think that's exactly what we saw
andrew slow
start but what did he have he had an
amazing comeback
victory and that's exactly what you
expect from a 3350 caliber bullet player
and we were praising nihal for being
such a solid player even in
bullet i think that was his downfall he
was too solid and andrew was able to
neutralize any edge that he might have
had
we are going to go on a short break when
we return we'll be back with
andrew tang and we'll hear his thoughts
about that wonderful match win against
nielsen
[Music]
and robert and myself are back joined by
the winner
of that extremely exciting match uh
grandmaster andrew tang
hello andrew first of all i want to ask
you about the beginning of that match
we'll start with the bad news
obviously being down five to one how did
you even you know
mentally come out of that hole yeah that
was uh
pretty terrible to say the least but um
i kind of
realized that i was just getting beaten
out of the opening so
i felt like i wasn't exactly
totally just getting outplayed but i
needed to to switch things up
so i stopped playing that line of the
london i think
things got a lot better right away and
you actually cut the deficit to five to
three heading into the break
did the break come at a good time for
you because not only did you have the
momentum but as you just said you could
change your openings out
yeah i think okay it might have broken
my momentum a little bit but
it gave me a little bit of time and i
did check the previous games really
quickly
which uh confirmed that that opening was
not good for me so
i think that was pretty important i
think actually openings can be
being quite important in matches like
these even if it's bullet
yeah completely agree especially when
things are moving so quickly it's hard
to
adapt when you get to the next game and
as the match progressed
it actually got to a point where you
were the one stringing games and games
together were you
conscious of the match clock like you
knew you had enough time to make this
comeback
yeah actually i was i was keeping a
close eye on that so i i saw when it was
seven to four i knew i had to win the
last three games
um and of course i knew i won the match
after that draw
i don't think nate hall did so um
that was lucky for me maybe but uh yeah
no i knew i had to win those games so
just full focus mode
and yeah he was seemingly in disbelief
at the match being over there but
we were in disbelief if your ability to
flag me hall
in one of the earlier games like the two
rooks against each other your king was
getting mated
then all of a sudden you decide to turn
on the jets and win on time
what goes through your mind when you
have just like one
two three seconds remaining and you're
trying to fend off an attack and then
switch that mentality to win on time
yeah so he obviously like should have
put me away there but
um i just have to try to prevent as many
mates as possible and he gave me this
opportunity i saw i could give him like
several checks repeating
so that's like that's perfect when you
have such little time i have easy
pre-moves and
it's just much easier for me to play i
knew i could throw in a couple more
checks at the end
and you flag your opponent like 95
of the time there there you go robert
you heard the stats flagging strategy
snapple fact number 637 got it
that's uh that's that's a good one well
andrew i wanted to ask you as well
what you make of your opponent nihal
because he we found him super impressive
in this competition overall
and then obviously he made it all the
way here even managed to get up five to
one
against uh yourself is this an opponent
that you've played a lot online because
he was certainly impressive in this
tournament we found yeah for sure
um he's definitely he's gotten very very
good at bullet recently especially
and i have played him a lot recently and
i've
had actually pretty bad results against
him so um
i wasn't looking forward to this pairing
at all
but uh yeah that's that's just how it
goes
i think he's definitely an especially
difficult pairing for me
well speaking of pairings and players
you played many times
your semi-final matchup will be against
donya nareditsky
you played him countless times how many
times do you think you played that
a couple thousand at least for sure and
well what's the difference between
playing him in all those previous games
many of which are streamed and
kind of played more for fun versus
playing in a timed match
where you know that you don't have time
to make up ground as if you're playing
endlessly
how does the mindset change yeah
definitely i think uh
getting to a good start is is very
important i
don't want to repeat what happened today
but
i don't know it's interesting because i
feel like recently we've
we've been playing always like while
streaming so
i'm just looking forward to having like
a
serious match with high stakes with
tanya
for sure and last question before we let
you go i know that was a taxing match
what what shirt are you wearing right
now is that a ah that is my jersey yeah
yeah okay i just wanted you know be
proud about it you're andrew
c9 representing the esports org and do
you think people were watching you did
they send you messages of support you
know what's that like
i think probably if i open discord right
now i'll have a lot of messages but
i haven't checked yet so i hope so
well we're sure that they are supporting
you and rooney for you i know every time
i go on twitter after one of your
matches
they're tweeting about it but congrats
andrew really just a fine performance to
come back from a 5-1 deficit and defeat
such a strong player
you move on the semi-finals we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow thank you
there we have it that was uh
grand master andrew tang uh always a
nice interview and nice to hear his
thoughts especially
robert that five to one lead that was
opening up uh just
to hear what he was thinking and how he
was able to turn that around really
insightful
yeah it's great to hear a player's
thoughts and in specific moments where
you're wondering how do they know what
to do
he just told you 95 of the time if you
can make a repetition and then you stop
making that repetition
you can flag your opponent but next we
have hikaru nakamura
against arjun aragasi not somebody to
take lightly we know hikaru
the heavy favorite he won pretty much
all the qualifiers he played in
he's the reigning bullet champion but
arjun just knocked off lavonna rodin who
to be fair doesn't play that much bullet
chest online but is a super grab master
and show that he can really play bullet
chess
yep a hundred percent there's uh there's
no doubt in my mind that he deserves to
be here
um there's also no doubt in my mind that
he car was the clear favorite
but that's the type of matchup you can
expect from you know the
number one seed and the number eight
seed in the bullet chess championship
picard is also the defending champion
here
and arjun showed some tenacious defense
yesterday
and that can come in handy because
hikaru is the stronger player we know
he's higher rated in
well all formats but if you can put that
defense up
and make your opponent's life as
difficult as possible that's a grueling
effort and we're human we make mistakes
yeah and you know if you if you start to
list the ways that it's possible to beat
car nakamura and bullet i mean it's a
very short list so
you sort of have to pick your style you
either go toe to toe with him tactically
and you know just be ready for the
skirmish on the board
and the other option robert is trying to
flag the guy and
that's pretty hard as well he car's not
the fastest player on the planet and
believe me there are faster players than
he covered but the thing that he does
the best
is he had plays with such high accuracy
so tactically sound during the game that
it's not that he's so quick with the
mouse it's that his moves are so strong
it's hard to react to them quickly and
here we are we're with the
chicago the b3 systems and move one and
arjun played very quickly out of the
opening yesterday
against levon aronian so we'll see if he
can keep that up because as you just
said the one way
that hikar could possibly lose these
games really is on the clock and right
now hikaru
just jumped jumping out of the opening
here with a lead of five seconds
yeah rook d3 and the nice thing with
rook d3 it's flexible you can double on
the d
file or the e file he goes for the e
file and he might i'm just gonna say
might take with the pawn there but he
decides to keep
that triple uh pressure on the e file
opened up and look at how quickly i
wasn't even looking at the queen side
he's saying i'm gonna take on e5 with
the rook so i can go win a pawn over
there that
doesn't seem too relevant but a pawn is
a pawn
yep 100 percent true that is uh just
full board vision yes and now he's up a
pawn
still can't do anything with it just yet
and queen f5 played
trying to keep the tension alive and
bishop f6 so no more tension
and also no more bishop against knight
dynamic and look at that
pawn takes f6 that awareness from arjun
that way he can keep
the pawn on d5 yeah and the hikaru
definitely better positionally speaking
but uh he threw a little bit of his
advantage maybe a lot of his advantage
uh away there
he did and now it's a rookie game even
material and in fact the pawn shocks are
on the king side not that bad if these
pawns get traded over here on the queen
side
the game should be just strong but he
dropped the h5 pawn
yeah that's just structurally you have
to be aware of that uh
once again i credit carl's full board
vision there he took a pawn on a5
and h5 this game and the problem here
for black isn't the board it's actually
the time because
i think on the board this should be
close to a theoretically
uh drawn drawable game i should say but
now with the king on f4 h5 check at any
moment
you're just going to try to beat him on
the clock yeah king f5
annoying move here because you have that
rook f4 to block and you can see the
evaluation bar hovering around equal
and look at this kingdom g5 very smart
by arjun i think f5 he's
he's able to trade off the remaining
pawns but the problem is
the rooks work against is not a draw f5
now he might save this
oh my gosh if he saves this there he
goes let's take the pawn
king g3 oh he's promoted to a knight
though
oh no it's not that oh gosh oh man
oh he doesn't get it he doesn't get it
he doesn't get it
so close i mean he really worked for
that he really worked the problem was
he wasn't supposed to and he didn't want
to play rook h8 rook takes h6
you want to wait as many moves as
possible but when you're playing bullet
sometimes you have to skip those steps
because you want to make the position
the easiest as possible to pre-move
and so many things were happening there
that i didn't even know what i was
saying i started promoting to a night
and i wondered what am i talking about
so
that was crazy hikaru too quick for
arjun in that one arjun put up great
defense is what we highlighted before
the match began
and right now arjun's up a pawn out of
the opening with white
great opening i mean yeah rook back to
d2 he goes rook b6 but
at this point b3 just be solid you've
got that extra pawn and look at
e4 is so well defended as well okay so
just don't hang your knight in a forward
bring that back to c3
bishop six knight d5 you've worked with
the b3 squad to run back two
right and that's exactly i mean you're
calling the whole game so far that's
what he needs
and f5 there we go something from hikaru
to
uh you know spice things up in the
middle and 95 so you take f5 you drop c4
so he just takes on c5
and he's still only up one pump at 97.
great awareness by arjun to use that
tactic
yeah tremendous play so far king e5 and
i feel like there's uh
mate something brewing here and he plays
g3 rook d2
hits the bishop and threatens rookie two
check do you have that here
that is a big move he takes in c6
instead which is still
two extra pawns but not not the bad move
at all
but arjun down on the clock even if he's
up several pawns
and he's trying to keep all of them and
i think he's succeeding as well
yeah he is you can even go bishop e3
king to d3 pawn to c5 things of that
nature
and he should be able to take this one
yeah this is one that yes you're down on
time
but you have 17 seconds and in total
that should be enough
but he's dropping the eight pawn so one
pawn's going down f6 he could put f6 and
rook f5 after that if he needed
yep 12 seconds i still feel like white's
the favorite here but he car is so
tricky i mean he's just the hard guy to
put away uh but bishop e5
really nicely done you get your king on
e6 you have rook b8 now
oh he doesn't play he's going for me he
supports a checkmate
that's beautiful with the awareness
robert i would have played rook b8 in a
heartbeat there
i wouldn't even thought twice about it
rook b8 would have been my move and
you're winning there but that threatens
checkmates you end the game remember you
can lose on time even if you're up a
queen
well done by arjun it is one to one will
hit karu bounce back in game three here
yeah and something we've seen from
almost every
uh of one of the favorites so far robert
has been
shaky starts yes and well hikar did win
the first game but
any start that's really not taking a
lead is a shaky start for someone as
strong as hikaru and right now
arjun playing on the king side hikari
lining those queen and bishops up on the
diagonal
knight g6 overlooked and that's a very
important pawn
because you go queen e7 knight g6 and
you just have to go back where you came
from upon down in a regular position
this one is a wash i think oh yeah now
you're down two pawns oh he pre-moved
king g6 because he thought knight g5 was
happening and
yeah that's that so 2-1 hikaru very good
game by hikar
he didn't do anything that spectacular
he didn't go out of his way
to go for tactics he played principal
chess and it paid off for him
yep you're 100 correct that is uh
sometimes all you need and we're back to
this type of position although it's
transformed into a benoni
yes and the binoni is very sharp and in
bullet chest that can go either way and
f5 is the idea for black he can't get it
off right yet because the queen on c2
pawn e4
covering the square and arjun he's
playing these well
and after f4 it is met by f5 because of
the hanging bishop on e3
which is still there so you might see
rook a to e1 no this looks
very problematic for black but maybe a
car will be able to survive knight g5
there
you can trade off try to open up more
files for your pieces go after the g6
pawn and
look at him look at arjun full board
awareness the b6 square the f5 square
problems for black everywhere yeah the
only thing is queen f7 is a nice move
and there's knight g3
knight f6 knight h5 cars pieces are
starting to find exactly where they want
to be
and rook takes e3 as a threat followed
by bishop d4
so he plays rook f3 to preemptively
defend that square and car
takes the i kind of like that decision
knight on e4 and i don't g3 but
uh look how quickly he took with the
bishop in bishop h4 that seemed a catchy
car
off guard yeah i think he forgot that
the h pawn could be captured like this
and now the d6 pawn is a bit vulnerable
here so how can you get after it bishop
e7 he goes for it right away
and there's no repetitions there's g
takes f5
and he pushes f6 to the pawn so you can
take on d6 yep
well what is happening here what's the
material count
he hung the knight he missed that it was
a fork
and he's still up he's got a really good
chance to flag here so he definitely
going to keep going and i looked at the
screen to see how hikar's reaction was
but he is streaming and his
camera's being captured from stream so
there is some delay that's why you saw
him slap his head when he
a little bit later than it actually
happened on a different move yeah yes
and oh this king should be mated soon
rook moves somewhere bishop you need
bishop f6
look at that move knight d4 knight at
five check rook g7
oh my gosh 83 is a good pre-move but
there's no mate there's no mate rookie
one there's brook takes c3
oh my gosh the movie so quickly oh no
that's bad for arjun and hikaru is too
fast and he takes the game
yep yeah and this i mean you can see the
the camera reactions there
nobody's happy with that one no
no and okay we're on to game
five now three to one for hikar arjun
was
really just a tad away from taking that
game and tying it up two to two so he's
right in this match but he cannot afford
to drop games like that because hikar
won't give you too many chances
it's it's so true that you know ray when
you feel early on in these matches that
you have a chance against chicago the
problem is if you miss all of those
chances
the score starts to add up you don't
even realize it's getting away from you
that's true and we have another knight
in e5 we saw this earlier hitting the
rook on d7 rook f3 is a threat knight c6
would have been a threat the rook didn't
go d6 so
i like what hit car is doing but i think
arjun looked at mcqueen e4
a fine way to trade queens and that pawn
on a3 vulnerable if it was on a2
a lot different i i think but ooh not
sure about that move
and structure and there was a knight d2
instead of a knight c5 available to
arjun that he didn't go for
and now the problem is that blacks pawns
extra ones in the center
and that look at the black pawns stuck
on dark squares h6 c5
ae7 that bishop on c1 can attack whereas
the bishop
f8 is stuck to defense and this is uh
i mean the b4 you have to favor white
here i've really
thought that uh picaro getting his pawn
to h5
was was the difference in this game and
look at this you can take
f4 when he wants it but push that c pawn
c6 you can't even stop
it and that's a win for your car yeah
this is what i was talking about it
starts to add up robert you don't even
realize
that it's happening and all of a sudden
he's getting a two three
four game lead and it's four to one
hikaru nakamura we did just see andrew
tang
storm back from a 5-1 deficit
unfortunately for arjun well he's facing
the car nakamura he's not gonna give you
too many chances
but i think arjun he needs to do
something in this game
and wow it's getting sharp and i don't
really like white's position at all
yeah i don't don't know what line this
is
but with missing the center pawn like
that this doesn't feel right
and i'm just looking at the players and
arjun just hasn't reacted at all
he just is kind of there and just
playing game by game you wouldn't know
how he's doing in his positions
exactly he's he's telling nothing he's
telling nothing some players like to
look at the webcams when they're playing
right and the c4 just dropped oh why is
he not taking c4
it should be well i think he's i think
he's concerned about bishop b7 c6 which
is why
yeah i mean that okay but bishop a6 and
brook be to this rook d8 is to be very
careful if you're black here
yep knight d4 coming as well oh
so he's thinking it was king f8
just like such a hikara move it's like
okay i'm not even going to take your
pawns with my king here but now you're
down
are you not down any material but you
are essentially it's two extra points
for white and the queen side and those
pawns are mobile
and there's two extra pawns in the
center for black those pawns not as
advanced
keep in mind arjun is the one who's up
on time here hikaru thought a lot about
the
the ramifications of bishop takes b7 so
he's down
five six seven seconds here oh wait
okay those pawns are a bit vulnerable
knight to three
yep key fighters f3 so you can't bring
your king forward just
move b5 yeah i think that's smart and
then a4 just keep pushing those pawns
because i'm wondering what does black do
what oh my god what a move
oh my wait what's happening here are you
queen on e1 and stop 97.
and the a7 pawn guards b6
wait a second he should have started
with b6 if white had started with b6
knight d5 would have stared in both
we could maybe show this later but that
is wild
and all of a sudden he flips that around
that was
insane hikaru is just he's so
tactically alert and there's 18 minutes
25 seconds remaining
plenty of time here for arjun to catch
up but
good luck catching up with a car is
playing like this he's gonna have to
take a page out of the
the cloud nine handbook that uh andrew
had because five to one is a
score line we've seen come back from
before but
he's going to do the exact same thing
here against an even tougher opponent
all right so we see a trade on e5
position starting to open up a bit both
kings in the center
black about to castle though so to count
the safety knight takes e5
i mean they felt like their tactics on
the e5 square definitely
definitely like those are the things
that you're you're looking for here if
bishop to e3 then you're 100 right the
queen is staring at the e3 bishop
right so now the queen trade is being
offered and that looks a lot less
promising
for black but it takes the knight there
that's such a weird decision this whole
game is catching me off guard here but i
guess white is first the action the a7
pawn falls there's a pin on the bishop
on d7 to the other bishop on e7
right and this knight g5 wait knight 65
knight takes e5 because bishop c5 check
oh that's such a great tactic
and instead he falls into he falls into
a tactic of his own
and look at h6 so open up the seventh
rank mm-hmm
ricky knight d6
and now rook c1 oh my gosh
and now it covers down a piece he
dropped that and
it's just still such a tough position to
get out of though yeah he just hung a
piece back on d6 the bishop was pinned
h5 he's just gonna resign yeah
wow wow okay well it was almost like
hanging a piece was the best way for
hikaru to win that game this is the most
efficient way
yeah because his position clarified and
arjun had the
extra material and the advantage
objectively speaking but practically
every single move is difficult to play
yep
and we get back to this benoni structure
and
okay then i just wrapped around a c7
he's not playing for f5
in this particular position it seems
like white should have an edge
yeah the fact that this knight got to b4
is not always the worst because white's
sort of trying to play around that
that piece for now knight c4 might see
something like queen c1
targeting h6 as well but e5 is gonna
crash through instead
yeah this d5 pawn should not be captured
there's a rook on d1 staring at the
black queen on d8
you can think about playing d6 and he
takes their first
wow look how quickly he was aiming for
rookie eight
right and i'm not sure because there's
i mean the rook's defended by the bishop
yeah the knights look a little clumsy
all of a sudden
oh and wait knight d3 cutting off the
queen for the night and then the f2 pawn
oh that's such a strong move maybe d6
you might try to throw in here
yeah probably the only way but at the
dccc bishop d8 or something
oh knight f4 happened or knight e1 was
made 91 would have ended the game
yeah knight e1 queen e4 queen f1 bishop
d6
and hikaru up you know 15 ish seconds
and
yeah there's much time too much time
he's got checks and checks and checks
he's got a bishop to bring into the
action
and it's a bishop d4 you can take and
there's
wait can you two he's taking all the
pawns and then you have to check oh he
saw everything
that's incredible that was all forced
yeah that was all forced
yeah i think it might have been
available on the turn before but he was
just bringing the bishop in and then he
probably noticed that
that's like icaru puzzle rush right
there yeah
and well i think we're at our half time
here it is
seven to one in nicaragua's favor after
that last game
amman i would ask you for words of
advice for arjun
but i don't know if anything we say can
help at this point
no because i mean i'm barely keeping up
with hikaru's calculations here
robert when you i think there's nothing
that that humanizes you more than trying
to commentate on a hikaru bullet game
like i'm five moves behind and i'm
wondering
how arjun is even keeping up like he's
had some chances in these games
which is very impressive but it's sort
of that sentiment that i was hinting at
earlier where
you'd lose one you lose two they're all
really really close like
just one move you feel like your car's
got cover and you're like oh man i had
it or
i should have flagged that and then you
look at the score and you're down by six
well i'm out of ideas right now which
means it's time for our break
when we return we'll be back for the
second half of this match between hikaru
nakamura
and arjun irigase in the bullet chest
championship presented by sig
[Music]
we are in the middle of our second match
of the day hikaru nakamura leads 7-1
over arjun ira gazi earlier today
andrew tang took down nihal sard eight
and a half seven half but he did face
a huge deficit he was able to work his
way back
unfortunately for arjun seems not very
likely down
six points with only 15 minutes to go
yeah he i think at this point what uh
this type of score line indicates
is that arjun basically needs the exact
same score line
in the second half so he needs to score
seven to one against hikaru which is
uh that's not something that anyone is
going to bet money on themselves
to do no unfortunately not and arjun has
played well he's had some opportunities
but
hikaru has worked through these
tacticals tactical sequences i should
say
moves in advance he's been really
impressive and he's been alert and of
course
he's going to be disappointed with
himself he always is he's his own
harshest critic
when it comes to his chest but we've
been extremely impressed thus far
yeah and that's the thing when you're
33.50
regularly stuff like this won't impress
you because this is what he expects from
himself so
the thing is he's actually been
blundering but if arjun was picking up
every single blunder
then he would probably be right back in
this match and we see that arjun is
resorting to the french defense and with
the 94 variation
which we saw him catch lavon ronin off
garden with that queen h4 check because
levana pre-moved f4 but here
we get back to what we saw a few games
ago black trying to
break down the center white's king still
uncastled
black finally castling and no p7 traded
no and look at this every single pawn uh
oriented like a checkerboard for hikaru
nakamura here
all on the dark squares safe to say that
uh his light square bishop might be
pretty strong this game
yes and it looks like arjun was quick
enough to
break down the uh queen side and the
king is still on e1
in my head the king was on g1 and castle
but no that king finally gets to f2
and runs away so maybe not so terrible
for
white despite the awkward start to the
game yeah because all of a sudden he's
got that e5 square and
i mean that just really really helps
when you're behind in development
trying to catch back up if there's a
closed position that gives you time to
do that
that's right the king could run from e1
to h2 and now he's
looking shifting those rooks to the
queen side i still think black's
position is perfectly good here
but it's not easy to come up with a plan
yeah king h7 i would
play in a heartbeat just get that king
to h7 safety
off the back rank off the diagonal for
checks and e3 is hanging but there must
be some kind of
checkmate back there queen takes c5 it
takes d5 oh my gosh
wait no there's queen d at the end
there's queen d8 it's a queen c5
threatening queen f8 queen h8 or queen
c8 shack going for a similar kind of
mates
how how does this work that's amazing
queen c5 queen f8 and queen c8 and it
just
it's just me unbelievable
it's just made queen c5 there
i tell you what uh queen c5 if you
played it i would have told you it was a
mouse slit for queen takes d5
my brilliancy i do wonder if hikaru saw
that one in advance or he suddenly
realized queen takes d5 didn't work
because he paused for a second there and
if you saw the knockout queen c5 maybe
you'd play it more quickly i'd be
curious to
know if he saw it the whole way through
well i mean that's
uh definitely something that's on all of
our minds but benefit of the doubt is
something that you can
can give hikaru nakamura and bullet
without uh worrying too much
that is true although in this position
it looks like arjun gets off to a good
start that d-pawn is pinned
even material it looks like white is
doing well here and yet
he's starting to spend time unsure how
to continue but how many times have we
said that in this match arjun off to a
great start and now he's spending some
time
unsure how to you know i feel like
that's almost the story of every single
game
and look at this move rook a6 to then
give up the pawn c7 and go 96. i just
unbelievable how quickly these resources
are found
yeah and it's just going to be d5 next i
think or even pawn takes but it
broke b8 he's giving that up and he says
look i'm upon down but
position is more manageable than it was
before although i think all things can
say this is the
worst way to be down a pawn like if
you'd gone d5 as you suggested
uh it's not as clear-cut how white
continues here
yep so it takes oh the g3
i mean just hate when you think robert
right when you think okay king h2
and the rook is hanging with his 94
check what is happening here
there's a rook on the idiot hanging and
he's going 94 but it's too slow
taking oh my goodness is this finally
gonna be a win
it actually is hikaru got got out tactic
or forgot about it whatever it is
somehow arjun came out on top that one
and that position i think was even
winning without the knight like the king
and pawn in the game
right exactly oh gosh so he hit a knight
to spare
and finally arjun or eric i see after
all those tactical sequences
he gets a victory and it's well earned
and
it's still eight to two my
goodness that is uh quite the game now
again arjun back to these types of
positions
i have to say they're working out for
him every time he just basically plays
like some sort of combination of
a5 f takes e5 and knight h6 and
he always gets a good position although
here the pawns are doubled which means
the black king isn't that safe i play
king h8 just run my king in the corner i
know i'm giving up the h6 pawn
but look at him go he's trying to
protect his king rook g7 the next one
come over to f8
and go for a counter attack right and at
some point do you throw an
a5 like you need some counter play over
there i think a5 would have been a good
move
yeah you need to do something on that
side of the board plays it now
king just runs to f2 cars
no castling chess he has a good sense
though of these positions where he's not
castling ever
but his king can always safely run
saying with king f2 king g1 is
going to go king h2 i guess yeah very
impressive he takes the time
he he gets a position where he can spend
four moves with his king and not end up
in just a lost position
and i like that decision by arjuna to
take on john the bishop so he keeps that
knight there which means some kind of
knight h3 check knight f3 check
there has to be an eye kept off at
knight f3 now takes d4
there you go i mean that looks good
enough to me but knight f6
careful and queen f6 also queen f6 and
just through three and queen g7 queen d8
oh it takes right away queen f6 was
needed i think and great move 93
bringing the knight
back towards the black king and for an
attack and now knight takes d1
oh my gosh wow queenie won after he has
to take it
queen h6 i think e5 was hanging there so
that would have been better than this by
black but
still such an impressive defense yeah to
not have already lost the game queen
three check would have won the
e5 pawn so he plays b4 kingy seven
night quincy five checks he's up one
time he's up on time wow
he doesn't want the draw he king d8 run
runs oh he ran into me
oh my gosh queen c8 was just the worst
move to play you want to play king d8
but he played queen c8 boxed himself
in oh my gosh and he just saw that with
1.5 seconds on his clock yep that's
icaru
unbelievable and arden still hasn't
really reacted by the way he still has
the same posture he's had the whole time
i mean
man he's he's just got this he's got
this face like
he's just it's just hitting him slowly
yeah
and it's like what more can you do right
yeah exactly
what more can you do he car was playing
like this how you supposed to beat him
well the winner of artemia versus
farrugia
and that's your next opponent for hikaru
so
they'll have to answer it because we
can't yeah that's that's
why we commentate let someone else
handle that
and arjun is now up two pawns so
two pass one pass pawn and another pawn
that can help out with e5 eventually
this should i know i've said it before
but
as far as the games go this feels like
one of the clearest advantages he's had
yeah takes and he takes on g6 even yeah
e6 is hanging
okay chad g6 is hanging back and d8
oh oh no bishop bishop gt just don't
take it
yeah oh knight c4 forks the rooks
this also obviously works because you're
up a full rook and two pawns
all right so he is going to take this
one right yes
he took this one there we go there we go
nine to three seven plus minutes
remaining
so arjun you could strength together a
few victories and just
start taking away reading points from
acara and it's crazy when you start to
think of the
the game's past that you could switch
the result for
you start to eventually get to a score
that is very very level i mean arjun has
had
real winning chances in at least like
you know
two to three games like real winning
chances yeah there was that one game
where he was at a piece and he ended up
flagging and things like that it's just
in that game we just saw before where he
got checkmated when a car was down to
his last
second so really impressive by icaru to
manage that in the time travel and
credits arjun for
making this a difficult match the i
think the score doesn't quite indicate
how close these games have been
and right now hikaru trying to push his
queen side pawns and
well i actually don't see 92 here just
okay 95
i like that less because it's not stable
yeah the thing is knight d2 bishop a5
bishop e5 was needed and you know if you
don't spot that in in the moment then 95
more aggressive maybe makes sense
and look at this bishop c7 you take a7 i
take a5 so right now black is up a pawn
and the eval bar i see likes white so
[Music]
yeah because if you go b6 and then a6
there's b5 and knight b6
to hold everything that's right and
after b6 maybe you can
take you know with a piece on b6 but
right now king d3 is the threat
i'm just kicking the knight out yeah and
it just hasn't
been met so he loses d6 can be played or
a knight back
okay good effort with king d7 you still
can't take the knight because the pawn
is going to promote
incredible and the knight stops the king
from advancing there's nothing to do
wow just a little fortress over there a6
a7
oh no it's still a6 knight f2
i mean may as well take that there's the
e pawn that's running yeah
oh my gosh and the king b7 okay you took
first
you can try to take all those pawns with
knight g4 oh
knight h2 yeah that might be a problem
he took that palm he's no time so it
didn't matter because he was on the
clock
yep wow just wow it's funny because
we're trying to work through the
complications of the position
and maybe hikar wasn't finding all the
knockouts but he's moving so quickly
that arjun just
has no time left even when the horse is
behind him and that's that's like a
knockout in itself
when you play so fast that your opponent
doesn't even have time
literally no time to process the the you
know how
convoluted the complications are that's
that's also just a way to out calculate
your opponent
think quicker than them and don't give
them them time to think on your clock
that's right and it's gonna be a sack on
g5 right now because that's what i would
do in a bullet game and
probably not think twice about it arjun
says ah no i'll leave it there and bring
my knight around
solid though very so it's just like one
of the best positions for arjun out of
the opening
and now for the first time some pieces
have been traded before that moment
nothing had been traded
hikaru gives up a pawn which makes his
king worse and bishop d3 now oh i would
have
he should play bishop d3 and taking on
e4 with a piece
and hikara wants to play you know he
wants his knight c7 a6
uh c5 right take over the dark squares
and sometimes this works right you just
keep dark square control if you replace
that bishop on d7 with the bishop on e5
yep that looks great but unfortunately
at some point
white will likely be able to crash
through although white's down 10 seconds
he wants to play i was gonna say he
wants to just take and even though he's
trading queens
pawns are falling here white's better
but this is getting very tricky
and he's taking he's taking another pawn
but his pawns are hard to actually move
just yet so he goes king here and
there's a bishop to
play a4 and this rook is trying to
infiltrate on the b file
how is this that difficult it feels like
whites up so much material
i know but he can't get that knight out
of c5 and rook c7 knight a6 and it goes
back
yeah that's frustrating g3 thrown in
and he can't take the knight because
there's always rook b2 ideas and but
look how quickly he's playing
he car was so good at this stuff yeah it
rooks
c7 that's what i'm looking at yeah oh my
goodness you can't even take g3
nope and knight takes e4 is happening in
the next few moves oh my goodness
this turned around so quickly oh but
wait but rj gets out of this rook c7
oh he had rook c7 there yeah
his his king back to g2 was not what the
the position needed no he's just gonna
lose some time despite
now finally getting his king all the way
away
that's the problem is that as soon as
you you know maybe get hikaru
tactically which is rare he's always got
more time than you
he is exceptionally speedy and arjun now
down 11 to three and
i really wish i had any words of
inspiration or just something to fix
because i just don't know how you take
down hikaru
you were right though that i think speed
will be if anything hikaru's kryptonite
because
it's it's clear that arjun can keep pace
on the board in terms of
tactics and things like that but even
when hikar's bad position he's ahead in
the clock so
whether it's farouza or temiev it will
be interesting to see if they can
just play more quickly than arjun did
and give
hikaru more of a run for his money
exactly exactly and we
you know see a performance here from
arjun haragasi that is you know
not one to be uh to be shy of i mean
this is this is definitely a good
performance by him he's put some points
on the board the problem is
i think that he car is playing even
better than you know some
hikarus that show up on other days like
he is really playing well right now
he's a king on h4 i mean that's just
kg5 you know get checked in a few moves
but it was worth it for sure
yeah and i think white's just crushing
here because of the h-file control
yeah just move that bishop on e3 and
make some big-time threats on the e6
bond and look at this b4 you get that
bishop and he sacrificed the bond
oh gosh queenie fights mate this is
gonna hurt me queen e5 is mate
wow yeah look at the final position it's
just very visual
oh gosh right you didn't even have to
trade things and then break through no
no you just checked me
with all those pieces around there
yep whoo well i think this might be the
last game robert as
uh bishop takes f6 and knight c7 played
by arjun opposite bishops here unless
this is a quick draw
pretty sure this is our last game yeah
and i don't think either player is too
unhappy about that hikaru
he's you know maybe he wants to keep
playing i don't know but he's about to
end this match with a you know eight or
more
match victory and for arjun it's like
i've had enough
this has been fun he said he wants to
play the toughest competition
he got his wish and well it's been a
hard time
yeah there you go you're playing the
toughest competition literally
and all right white is up a pawn here
but the bishop isn't particularly good
and now he's the b file so he has
some chances but we saw that knight on
c5 in the previous game where his car
was black
there it is again yeah and this is once
again going to be tough
to remove from the position and look at
the white king
black is just better here after losing a
pawn yep
taken upon f2 rook b2 can be played the
king on f1 probably will get checkmated
at some point soon
rook f2 check rook f5 then rick up one
mate is the immediate threat
yes mate yeah this is this should be
mate yeah well rookie
rookie too e2 and rookie one pre-move
yeah
wow wow wow
and i wish i had more to say but i think
wow sums it up
pretty well wouldn't you say yeah i i i
a few wows from me
uh as well i think that the chat
probably echoing uh those sentiments i
mean
this is just an impressive match uh a
crush we have to say obviously a bit
expected maybe for some people but
arjun is uh very strong player so
when someone makes him look for some
reason like he's not
then he's he's even better that's what
that means yeah arjun
really came out hikaru in some games he
was better in some he
just couldn't maintain both the position
and the speed at the same time that
combination
is what makes people bullet champions
and unfortunately for arjun who had a
great showing yesterday and played good
bullet chest today
just couldn't make it work so on that
note we are going to
take a break and win return will be
joined by hikaru nakamura who just made
his way
to the semi-finals of this bullet chess
championship presented by
sig
[Music]
and we are back robert and myself are
pleased to be joined by grand master
hikaru nakamura victorious
with a pretty convincing score hikaru
what is it like going into these matches
being on paper
such a clear favorite against your
opponent yeah i mean i think the first
thing
um is that the time that they're only
being 30 minutes for the entire match
you're not really sure what's gonna
happen
um i think getting off to a good start
is really really critical sometimes you
can overcome it like we saw in that
previous match between uh nihal saren
and andrew tang but
that's where the nerves are because just
at the start you won't want to do well
and you saw i lost that second game
after i won the first one then kind of i
got got in a groove and won a few
but i think the main thing is just got
off to a good start nothing else really
because
with only 30 minutes you get off to a
bad start it can become pretty pretty
pretty dicey
yeah that makes sense and you were
actually up on the clock in many of the
games was that a concerted effort on
your part to
remain ahead on time even if you know
there are moments in the game where
in under normal circumstances you'd want
to spend more time to figure out the
position
yeah i mean i think it really depends on
the kind of positions that you get i
felt the positions that we that i had in
this
in this match for the most part
excluding some of the french games which
were not very good
um was that was that you just want to
get to move 20 without really thinking
so i tried to just play natural
moves that made a lot of sense and i
think um if you make natural moves and
you avoid major blunders you're always
gonna have a chance in the game like
there were a couple of end games where i
was worse if not losing but they were a
little bit tricky so being up like five
to ten seconds made a big difference
and um i think that's sort of contrast
you either can use your time and try to
get the winning positions
um or you can or you can sort of just
blitz it and trust yourself not to make
the big mistakes and it certainly paid
off because
i felt that in quite a few of those
games i was much worse but ari june
didn't have enough time to capitalize
and win the games
yeah that seems like a pretty accurate
summary now to most people
on twitch obviously everyone's very
familiar with yu hikar probably less so
with
your opponent were you familiar at all
with arjun
and some of his games maybe from playing
him online previously
yeah i've played him um quite a bit and
he's done very well against me and blitz
like 3-0 and 3-1
i also i vaguely recall um something i
think kramnik
spoke about him in an interview maybe a
year a year and a half ago so i
definitely had heard of him um
and yeah i knew he wouldn't be a
pushover i've played him quite a bit
fortunately but he's a very strong
player and he's a bright future ahead of
him once
over the board chess resumes absolutely
and speaking of strong players you will
face the winner of the ali razor
ferrugia
and vladislav artemyev match i'm sure
you played against both of them
countless times at this point do you
have any indication of who might be the
favorite in their heads ahead
um i mean i assume that ali reza is the
favorite just because of
his rating and the fact that he he kind
of he's a star and blitz and bullet and
everything he won title tuesday earlier
but apparently
um apparently artemiv has a plus record
against him on both lead chess and
chess.com
so while i assume that alibaba's
favorite it seems that maybe there's
some psychology there on their
head-to-head and i think it's going to
be a very close match
yeah i think that that's obviously an
accurate summary and
uh just about maybe the final four
potential as it's shaping up to be
obviously farouza
or artemyev but also on the other side
of the bracket narediski
tang i mean hikaru just this final four
uh picture developing what do you make
of the competition as these are players
that you've probably
had a lot of experience playing on
stream yeah i
i feel like i mean the ratings don't lie
there's a reason that we're probably the
top four at the moment excluding a
certain world champion who doesn't play
obviously um i i think uh to me
i feel that ali reza is the most
dangerous player assuming he gets
through um
and then dania and andrew i mean that's
also a dog fight who knows uh who will
win and
win in that game but really at the end
of the day i think we've all played each
other so much that it's not really there
aren't gonna be that many surprises per
se in terms of like
you know you know what to expect from
your opponent in terms of opening and
the time usage
i think that sums it up hikaru thank you
so much for joining us and
congratulations on that really great
performance a dominant
performance against a very strong
argentine gacy so we look forward to
seeing you tomorrow in the semifinals
all right thank you guys thanks and that
was hikaru nakamura super grand master
the
most watched chess streamer on twitch
and he moves on
in this bullet just championship to the
semifinals he will await the winner
of the next matchup that we have ali
reza farouja
versus vladislav artemyev you heard it
from ikar himself that artemia actually
has a very
good record against farouja and yet fuji
is the higher rated player i think
better known to the public so what do
you think about that
amman as we get ready for that final
match of the day should be very exciting
uh no question about it i think this is
the one that's going to be the closest
head to head we actually had an insanely
close first match but
uh maybe people didn't expect it to be
that close this one i think everyone is
expecting to be as
car said complete dog fight between
these two players
first of all artemia in the interview
just the other day
he mentioned he doesn't really prefer
these no increment formats he probably
doesn't think of himself as the favorite
but
when it comes down to you know just
playing the match he's he's always there
full focus he's all about business
absolutely
and well these are some of the best
gamers on the planet and
if you want to use gaming skills in your
career
susquehanna international group is a
leading global propriety trading firm
that use game theory and decision
science to win in the financial markets
to learn more about sig
visit sig.com chess
and we have a great fight ahead of us
coming up
in our final quarter-final matchup here
in the bullet chess championship
we have ali rasa farouja against
vladislav artemyev this is two super
grand masters
as hikaru himself just said recently
known as this absolute
monster but i think artemiev he'll have
something to say about this as he's won
several the recent title tuesdays i
think he said he's won three
total or was it five total whatever it
is it's a lot compared to most other
people
so i think that this will be a very
hard-fought battle i wouldn't be
surprised if furuja comes on top i do
think he is the favorite
but something about artemyev always
makes me want to
bet on him yeah farouza also speaking of
title tuesdays uh
he also won today as far as far as i
remember
i was watching that earlier so obviously
ferruja in good form today
and i think it's no secret when you're
playing good blitz you're also generally
playing good bullet like it sort of
translates to
all areas so good title tuesday
performance is exactly what he needs
about to get into this match here but i
think
i think ali reza is going to be very
very
prepared for this match you know he's
full focus there's something
different about what you mentioned a lot
of these guys play each other on stream
robert but
now that they're playing off stream they
they don't have to you know interact
with the chat and that's not really
something they're considering
uh i think that we're in for an even
higher quality match
well ferruja what title tuesday today as
you mentioned how much winning can
somebody do in a single day i mean
the answer can be a ton i think hikaru
won both of the
qualifiers for the here bullet chess
championship so i guess it's possible to
keep on winning and not stop but
i don't know maybe artemis said enough
for you now it's my turn
right exactly and artemia uh this
this is a guy that people probably know
a bit less about but they did see that
previous match robert and
it was a very exciting one to say the
least so i think people are
ready for more of that from him getting
farouza in here and
speaking of ruja there is the match it
is underway and ali reza is up there
with 33.60
at the official weigh-ins robert yeah
it's casual you know just another day at
the office for
him and well artemis is almost 3 200
himself what
knight takes h4 this queen h5 check what
is this
hey everybody watching do not play this
yourselves i repeat
these may be some of the best players on
the planet do not play chess like this
please
is this not a free bishop i guess it's a
sacrifice i
what are we seeing i thought these guys
were 3 200 robert
oh gosh and what is this black is up a
piece he takes on h4 no fear
for martini if he removes the defender
of the knight on g5 this just looks
great
i have seen this position never amount
of times in my life
i can't believe i can say that on a
couple moves into like a regular
practically trapovsky attack yeah well i
don't think this is something that
alireza will be repeating we saw andrew
tang go with this opening that wasn't
working out for him
i mean now there's not a piece he's down
a full piece down a full piece
f3 uh also loose in this position queen
trade
obviously he's uh psyched about it d4
might even be falling
he's just gonna resign the game he's one
doesn't want any part of that
save time on the clock just admit that
that was just not it
and go next and our temiev is locked in
look at his face he's just playing chess
he's focused on the game here
not enough i've hit the g7p watch out
for knight g7 sacrifices
you may have protected it but that bish
1b2 would be happy to see that diagonal
be even more exposed
and talking about exposing that diagonal
in the g7 pawn look for moves like g4 in
this position and that's why h5 is
considered and played by ali reza
and look at our temperatures give me
that i'm going to take a pawn you make
it the bishop pair
your pawns in c7 and c6 are weak i
haven't castled yet
so your checkmating attack won't work
out because my king's still in the
center
i do like forge's activity though if
that activity is parried
then white should be better with the
pressure in the extra pawn
definitely and rook a5 look at that move
he needs to keep watching the f5 pawn
uh because the queen was there and
you've talked about that diagonal early
in the game robert that bishop on b2 is
saying
hello on the dark squish and now c6 can
be taken
even with the rook but then rook takes
a2 and so he plays bishop c3 so you can
take on f5 potentially if the rook takes
on a2
that king ng8 is in a world of trouble
yeah rook g5
at this point you're considering king f2
brook takes h5 and rook g1 swinging
all the pieces over to the attack and he
just goes 92 and trades and
at some point brook takes h5 can be
considered queen g3 hitting the c7 pawn
he overlooked it he could take that pawn
yep rookie 7 back but the problem is
look how compact the position is bishop
on h5 is
hitting a pawn that's defended otherwise
trapped he's going to take it and he's
going to take on f5 and then 94. and
he's just going to say
you may have an extra rook against my
knight i have several extra
pawns and my king is safe yeah and rook
f7 a good reaction
if black can trade queens keep in mind
that h-pawn runs it can be scarier than
you think
it just agrees on the draw that's a
practical choice by artemyev
who says oh i guess i missed some
opportunities now i'm getting some
danger you mentioned the h-pawn let's
just settle in draw i have a lead
and we go to game three and it's kind of
a kerocon gurgaon needs a system
and i think it's a solid approach more
timier and for ali raza not exactly the
style of position that he prefers
and that's a great uh great way to
describe
artemyev i think practical very
practical player and i think you're
going to see that
in the games today bishop e4 and he's
guarding f3
we've already talked about how double
pawns especially in front of your king
not something you want in bullet no less
and look at this 95 it actually gives up
a pawn because you can take a bunch of
times in e5
but your bishop on g4 is about to sit on
h5 and be uncomfortable your dark
squares in front of your king would be
weak
and that's why artemia practical player
did not take that knight on e5
all right and is this uh first of all f5
pawn loose but f6 f6
what a reaction like just to even think
of that
c4 okay you could take on g4 and
well you're at the very least even
material the c4 pawn is hanging as you
were just mentioning so
i think that our tenure can be perfectly
happy about this 100
and that bishop on h5 was not looking so
good but artemis
transformed that position uh around
completely and look at this rook d5 i
wouldn't have left the back rank but i
thought my rookie needed help and f5
i mean the guy is just playing classy
chess right now
yeah the rook on a1 is loose there and
he's getting the f5 break the bishop on
g7 opening up and all of a sudden it's
the white bishop that's locked in
and queenie one checkmate was a threat
that's why the king went to h1 to block
on g on the ball
oh look at that bishop robert everyone
pour one out for that bishop it's never
getting back in the game
that is as sad as it gets oh the rook is
trapped too
proper no every piece is trapped
and rook d7 rook d4 is made oh my god
he resigns down one pawn but all of his
pieces were trapped
like i've never seen a position with
like
relatively equal only one pawn advantage
for artemia but you could chalk that up
to like a -10 position because
the rook the bishop they're not playing
chess
wow that honestly was maybe our game of
the day there that was a really
impressive turnaround
for artemi of there and right now in
game four he's up two and a half half he
gets himself the c4 square
trying to go to d6 hits the rook hits
the pawn and b5 if you take on b5 your
knight would have been trapped which is
why i took that bishop
yep bishop on h3 so strong watching the
c8 square
might not look like anything but that's
an operative square for the c file for
the black
pieces here and it goes bishop g5 he
wants to get his rook over to c1 because
that rook is coming to c3 for black
but roxy three rooks he won his idea but
i wouldn't just take i would leave that
rook there
if you take me i get a pass fawn look at
that move bishop h6
bishop h6 and the c1 square
undefended i can't believe he's going
for this that c pawn looks very scary
oh but i guess usually if c2 queen c1
and 91
that pawn can't be defended wow
so i guess black was maybe supposed to
go queen take c3 queen a3
but hindsight 20 20. yeah it was that
was such a natural move and all of a
sudden our 10
but king f1 and queen take c2 if he
wants but the a3 pawn
is still going to be dropped right yeah
you want to play knight c2 but you're
walking into a pin
and the reason he hasn't played knight
c6 is queen c2 hits that knight
and look at this knight to e6 so if the
knight took then there would be knight
d4 that's what it took with the queen
and
he gives up the queen side pawns takes
the center i think black's pawns are
faster
yeah i think black's just winning queen
between b2 and the pawn is queening
eight two a1 and e5 yeah if you want to
take that
and king h6 no more checks for you a2
h8 is covered as well queen g7 king h7
yeah he's he's doing a good job i think
he's gonna have to play queen f8 there
wow what but what a fine buyer tim you
have to win that pawn
that looked game over and all of a
sudden he's fighting because that black
king isn't truly safe anymore
yeah it is something that you sort of
glaze over there but
that the series of checks that he
executed was extremely accurate
all right 27 you can't block 24 oh my
gosh
takes and takes on g3 and his king gets
there oh my goodness
oh my god i can't believe artemis he
caught every single pre-move
yes he did queenie two okay can you two
whatever just bring the king and queen's
fort
oh my gosh oh my goodness
and that is a reaction from artemia
usually he just
sits common there but he was upset with
himself that he didn't win that game
yeah i think uh that honestly comes from
experience
like in a bullet time scramble with one
to two seconds
there will be something that just you
know kicks in triggers that you've done
this before
and there's a specific technique for
that artemiev i mean he can do that in
his sleep but
not when there's one second on the clock
that is tough
yeah that was really just impressive
stuff then artemia
was down a piece right he was losing
that palm was promoting so
even though he was upset that's recency
bias like if he really thinks about that
game
already was out playing it but right now
with the black pieces or tamiya
his pieces are all on each other's toes
and white is up a pawn
although that bishop on f3 is sort of
operating as a pawn too
yeah i think here the fact that
both sides have expanded like the king
moving here is not a big deal look at it
king c2 we saw hikaru nakamura play like
10 bullet games without castling and hey
worked for him
and that's how you castle by hand right
you just move your king a bunch of times
and look yeah you castle queenside
and right now are tamiya trying to
battle on the queen side but
he's going on both sides of the board
and yet there's no breakthrough that
bishop on f3 i called it a pawn it's
laughing back at me
because it's just defending everything
yeah that's what pawns do
and bishop on f3 just saying please take
me correct the structure
g takes f3 and neither side wants to do
anything so b4
he's opening things on the other side of
the board where the action is
and and look at our timing just dart
over to the king's side but the d6 pawns
the potential weakness the b7 pawn
clearly
is something to be done with queen h4
there was rookie's b7 okay that bishop
was hanging
but it was a sacrifice he needs to go
for a7 there we go knight back to b5 i
was worried when he brought the knight
back to c3
i think a7 is the weakness and he
finally goes for it and look at that
taking on d6
winning the rook on c5 now just crashing
through all over the place
and i love that move a5 unfortunately
you're getting checkmated
yep we still love it though and that's
made in two on a7
right because you try to keep your king
closed you just happen to have no piece
of defending
but that's the way you save games like
that is this kind of quick a5 type moves
and artemyev the lead is cut to one
alireza with a
really blistering attack there and now
he should be feeling a bit more
confident getting in the zone
yep exactly and rook e8 here we see the
e5
uh intention by ali reza he is going to
do that but that makes the bishop on c4
pretty strong in these positions
that's true and the bishop one c8 needs
to get out at some point probably trying
to go to e6 and
all right now all of a sudden the pieces
are just clogged no trades have happened
yet
and g5 is what i'm looking for for
frucia yeah and will this knight on f1
reach the e3 square because it's even
better after g5 targeting those light
squares that
are now a bit weaker that's true and
even like d5
pawn sacrifice to open that bishop on c2
to take control of the light squares
he just goes for the pawn directly and
what just happened c3
look at that recognition by ferruja yeah
he baited him inside he went knight back
to f6 and
artemia was like wait give me that
central pawn oh and then right back to
h5
opening the diagonal so good although
wait what's happening here because
the f4 knight is a bit vulnerable 92
check wins the queen though
okay overlooked and it's still here
it's still there if you move the rook
there's 92 and now
both sides are realizing that yes and so
bishop d1 was played if you take on a1
he just takes back he needs to feel like
it's not the worst though because g4 is
hanging i
this is actually maybe okay can you just
take on g4 right now he doesn't the h2
knight will take and the h6
f6 squares this is dangerous this is not
that bad
oh queen at f1 what a move though queen
d3 just ignore
all these possible attacks so
knight d4 good rerouting they both have
15 seconds anyone's game
100 okay where's the check queen c1 king
h3
what a move to play an e5
takes e5 yeah no way this can pan out
your knight's actually trapped in f6
i go to h7 but then queen if i check he
almost came back in that game
uh that that was a really nice game by
ali reza though yeah it was and
moves like king h3 to shock me because
i'm just moving my knight around he said
i'll move my king up i'm safe and
right now for russia going for an
obscure opening where i don't think
white has any advantage in terms of a
classical chess dynamic
but he's making quick moves yeah and
that's the thing uh in bullet there's
that
fine line between the best move and the
quickest move and sometimes
they align perfectly and you fight you
play the best move very quickly
that's ideal bullet and look at that
move knight to b8 bishop c6 knight to d7
and he plays f5 just kicking that knight
out of there the e6 pawn
is a target and it's captured right away
but d3 is also hanging at some point
oh and all there is the same reaction as
i did he
baited him in there you were saying e6
weak and well you're 100 correct rookie
4 is a
great trick to try to use that pin from
h5 to d5 but artemia
too clean he just says yeah rook d8 and
so what
and yeah so what is right look at him
he's not even he's barely blinking
he just all right that's my game four to
three this really feels like
anyone's match at the start artemia was
winning game after game then alaresa
he found his form and then artania says
hey
you think you have a free problem but
not so fast partner my tactics are
a plus yeah and we knew this was going
to be a close match i didn't know it
would be this close they are trading
wins at this point and
every win feels like a tactical skirmish
and look at all the races rating by the
way all threes across the board
and we have trades here rookie three
make queen d4 next try to kick that
knight out of the center
okay there it goes d4 makes a lot of
sense and d5 i think that's the move
you're happy to see is white
yeah that's an isolated pawn there the
bishop one g2 will stare through the
knight at that pawn on d5 eventually and
well maybe you can
if you take that at five so watch out
for that yeah knight f5 the intention
queen f4 and now he wants to play rook
d3 i think and
that's just nice rerouting and there's
e4 for white there's knight g4 nothing
g6 right now oh
okay i didn't see it but knight tg6 it's
a typical tactic when queens are staring
at each other through a piece yep
now not possible though no would not go
for that
e4 played instead and well that knight
has to go to g7
and what's he waiting for just trying to
figure out i was yeah i was looking for
other squares
uh but g7 is the only one
honestly maybe he was worried about
getting back frank mate it's like funny
enough when you're knights on g7
you have an escape square but it's taken
by this awkward knight although now the
position's changed complaining what a
brave move to allow a discovered check
and a rookie seven mate but richie
richie oh this also should work right
yes you take the rook here but obviously
it's better to win a piece than when the
exchange
right and he'll be happy there's like
take on b7 okay white's still fighting
here
you have a pawn and a knife for rook an
id5 check you to watch out for rook a5
keep that pawn a7 under threat and the
clock
extra time for for our tamif
yep and the pieces are trying to
coordinate on f2 and they've done a
great job
here comes h4 speaking of trap pieces
that knight on each one
every single game yeah you have to play
f3 here and the problem with f3 is you
want to pump back on f2 now to like help
your king exactly so unfortunate
and this is i think gonna be a fairly
easy win for farrugia with time ticking
down as well
and he's ahead on the clock right now
yeah and we are
about to have half time it looks like
this will be the final game and
what an appropriate final game to have
yeah oh it's not over yet
it could be not over i i think ferrus is
just gonna do what uh
usually you do in bullet instead of
trying to convert that
on the board you say look i'm i'm
pre-moving you're pre-moving i have a
little bit more time
no sense in making this complicated
trying to play actual chess robert let's
just keep this flagging
and now it is four to four it is clear
that is anyone's match amman
it's harder to say in this match
compared to others of what the players
need to change so
if you take those last eight games into
account what do you think
each player can improve on and what do
you like that the players are doing
it's it's incredible like uh i feel like
we're dealing with two
very tactical players but um one thing
that i will point out is that farouza
is a little quick on the drop i feel of
a few games
he's taken something from our temiev and
it's been a total bait and he's had to
resign the game in like 10 moves or in
the middle
of the game you know and this is just
handing games to his opponents so
in a complete game i think ferruja has
has had the more impressive performance
but our time you have
is getting him in these tactics these
quick forks these opening tricks
and that's what's keeping this match
level right now so faruja
changes that up i think he could start
to pull away in just the complete game
format
that's a good point because there was
that one game where the queen takes f5
and artemy went f6 and all of a sudden
he took the advantage and then of course
when he went rook takes e6 and then
blundered that rook
and well i missed it too so i understand
your pain only raises but now we have a
4-4 match both sides playing well
tactically alert i would say a little
more alert is artemiev but i'll raise up
playing those quick
games where in time scrambles he's been
able to make his mark on that note
we will take a break there is so much
action remaining you will not want to
miss the end
of this ferrugar attended match stay
tuned we'll be back for more
from the bullet chess championship
presented by sig
i got into playing poker in college and
really liked it but
never considered i could make a career
out of it until jeffy ass came and gave
a talk at harvard
jeff explained that yes you can actually
use gaming skills for your career and
for something to do on a day-to-day
basis
which was exciting at the time i thought
it was really cool we can pretty much
guarantee you that we will give you the
best education
you will be taught all that we know in a
very professional manner by
expert teachers and you're going to be
mentored and i like to think that
there's no other place where you can get
as much mentorship as you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common
is a sense of competitiveness and
interest in
in gaming and strategy in general i
would say you're
you're playing a game as a career it's
very satisfying to me
that we've been able to employ so many
people give them not just an opportunity
to make a lot of money but to be with
the smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun make a lot of
friends and create a culture
of reason
[Music]
and we returned ready for the second
half of this match between ali reza
farouja
and vladislav artemyev the match is four
to four these are the four and five
seats so not
too surprising that it's this close but
i think the way the games have gone
that's a bit surprising so oman the
players had their break
we're ready for play to resume you
mentioned right before we left what the
players need to do i think that alireza
has been baited a bunch
but for artemyev what maybe does he need
to change
yeah we're getting back into this match
and i think that the break is kind of
well timed for ali reza who just needs
to sort of calm down
a little bit a little overzealous
grabbing things a little too quickly
uh for our temiev i think that if he
picks up the speed
that could that could really affect this
match because we know how quick ali reza
can be
but so far in this match i feel like
those those early games
uh farouza might start to second guess
himself keep himself in check
not blend these hanging pieces artemiev
can probably play the beginning parts of
these games
quicker than ali reza and you know if
you can get up on even time like three
four seconds early on
it adds up at the end of the game yeah i
honestly kind of want these two just
play matches and all time controls i
didn't expect the
necessary the bullet to be this close
but play some blitz play some rapid play
some classical
i will gladly watch or commentate all of
those because these two players
are two of the best in the world and
some of the most creative chess you'll
find
from them artemia have won the game of
the year against mateusz bartel recently
and so i mean just really fun stuff and
i don't know what to expect all i know
is going to be chaotic and i'm probably
going to lose my breath
we're here for it and the next match has
already started in case you were
thinking of catching your breath
well we're right back in this thing oh
yes we are we have this sort of modern
defense again
black is going to try to close down the
light squares and then eventually e6
knight to f5
and then try to play on the queen side a
bit and it's kind of like playing
checkers
and i think yeah bishop f2 and h4 this
is the idea
you want to close that down really
quickly such a solid opening here
i always find myself liking black in
this position just in bullet even though
you don't really have the most to do i
think alirez is playing this
fantastically
it's just i always have this preference
to those positions that are super solid
like this
and there was the problem for el alaresa
is that he didn't want to take on f5
necessarily but
black hasn't castled so b5 b4 and all
that stuff is happening very quickly
and the rook's coming to b8 the queen's
coming to b6 or a5 i actually think
white's king
is in a ton of trouble yeah and i mean
if black can get away with look at the
solid structure and also playing h
takes this is dangerous here and here
comes b three bishop takes a3 or knight
b6 knight a4 knight takes b2
just break down that pawn chain and go
for checkmate and black's king despite
being uncastled
perfectly safe and i was about to say
how do you stop it wait it's impossible
you had to play c
takes before there oh and you do not
want to do that but maybe alarisa will
be able to
fend this off p3 knight b2 is there rook
b6 rook a6 no you don't have time so a5
a4 is the idea rook c8 first to protect
the pawn
take on b2 it's with check remember that
c takes b to
check and look at this all the pawns are
falling you can take f4 you can take d4
oh gosh all of them fell down and rookie
one
is not out of the question yeah that
king c2 ticket
it's mate c2 is me pawn as well
you know how we're talking about
complete games and tactics that was both
that
was a fantastic showing by vladislav or
temiev
yeah it really was but i think that that
opening i i give that opening a huge uh
nod of approval in bullet
and it might be something that you
you're going to see uh farouza
actively stay away from in the future
yeah he might need to because that
went artemia was way easier for him to
play whoa look at that move c5
giving up a pawn to take control of the
c4 square and potentially the c file so
i like the idea by artemiev and
how do you cover d6 how do you keep a7
defended rook a5
all his pieces are flying into the
action and even queen d6 here is
playable rook takes a7 he has so many
different things he can capture e5 loose
as well
yeah he could have taken on b7 there
with a knight d6 fork now he can still
go knight d6 if rookie six knight takes
f7
all sorts of tactics available to white
and white has the safer king
okay knight takes f7 that's sometimes
the issue when you have so many good
things available if you don't know what
to pick
and white pick quickly there it goes the
kings on
e7 out in the open queen takes b4 is a
threat right
this looks okay i mean ali reza is
playing some tremendous defense
he really is now the f2 pawn's under
attack so you have to protect that
the bishop can come to g5 so he goes
bishop h6
rook d2 i guess go to the open fire but
that bishop c6 queen c5 97 configuration
is very solid yeah now f3 is an
important move you're going to see black
at some point
wish wishfully played g5 g4 to break
that up
but f3 is so solid here really keeping
the knights out
yeah and the question is whose king is
safer because at first glance it looks
like white's king should be safer
but if a knight comes to d4 and a queen
of d3 step one
hey you've got that both of those things
happening here knight f6 what a move
everything's covered here there's no
checks oh well now there's one there's a
big one a7 he lets it happen
knight c7 queen g7 oh queen g7 was good
now he allowed the knight back and
that's not what you want rookie seven
you get the pawn
yep but maybe black can get the f3 pawn
no he's looking to flag here i think
those knights are so tricky here
the knights are very triggered but i
love rook a1 keep the rook away from the
king no forks for you
mm-hmm oh
i thought just promoted the pawn f2 was
game
and this oh gosh this is going to be a
time scramble but white's playing too
slowly
yep yep and i think this is also should
be winning really really good technique
and will he play the rest of this on no
he's he he trusts sally reza
with that conversion and it's one of the
first times we've seen artemy have
missed that tactical shot with queen g7
check you called it out
yeah yeah that was that was a big mess
when the knights get defending one
another
they're really really compact and you
know just it's hard to make a threat
that was the one moment where they were
sort of far away from one another and
you could check
and well what's going on here it looks
like the pawn center is being attacked
with the knight and the queen now
and is there some kind of knight takes
d4 sometimes knight takes e5
tactics everywhere the thing is robert
this once again sort of reminds me of
that opening that i thought ali reza was
going to stay away from it is a little
bit different no f4 pushed here but
it's the same type of position i feel
like d4 is just
easily uh targetable and black has f6 if
he needs to
just such an easy game for the black
pieces okay there are some 95 d4 ideas i
don't know if they work though like
knight d65 and d4 but now that's out of
the question
and f6 you mentioned that moves still
going to be possible
absolutely and i think the last couple
moves have been pretty good for ali reza
we we
are waiting to see moves like h4 h5
and then look at that knight went from
c6 to g8 to save black's king it's a
preemptive defensive idea
i like it and now the knight's the c4
hitting b2 queen
oh take a3 is even better let's take
queen b3 and then take a3 but you're
right you could take it right away
you can stand yeah it does go for f6 i
think he just needed some space around
the king you know when the pieces are
starting to converge for white you get
that feeling and bullet like just the
safety thing oh let me get some space
it's counterintuitive because people
think that you save your king by keeping
all your pieces compact but look he
moves that pump played h5 and now the
queens are gone so his king is perfectly
safe and we'll see who can outplay the
other in this
ensuing rook end game yeah and there's
going to be knights
just this is a a nice dream this
position knight f5 knight e5
knight g5 yeah close i thought you just
walked into a pin
and look at this kink coming to g4 yeah
at some point
such an important move rookie three by
the way getting the rook in the position
in white's position before the knight
could keep it out and now the rook takes
d4 can be played it goes rook to b3
instead oh we hung g3
and now but the took the clock the clock
i think this is a lot easier to pre-move
with black
which means me
wow look how clumsy those pieces look at
the end rookie 2 knight g2 it's like
even material the king's like guys
what's going on this is really mate you
kidding me
smother checkmate you love to see it you
hate to face it and right now
our attention of going back to his b3
weapon a favorite of hikar nakamura we
saw him use it earlier and he plays f4
so this is
still vintage artemiev yep
takes f3 goes back so we might see some
sort of queen e1 to h4
which is usually the typical maneuver
but bishop takes c6
has to come in first because that bishop
out there could get trapped that's right
now queen e1 but look there's bishops
for black bishop on d6 which from
descent rook to g6 or h6 depending what
happens
i like black's position knight g5 is a
fantastic resource might even see rook
g6 threatening
knight h3 here yeah the one thing to be
careful is that f7 pawn which is why ali
reza played in this matter
but i liked your tactical ideas there
and so how do you actually protect e3
bishop before the c5 bishop c1 is just
sad
so he plays e4 and gives up a pawn i
guess that's the answer right there
knight g3 is going to be the follow-up
and if black
takes that knight trying to simplify
being up a pawn that's not so easy
it's much better to keep that bishop on
the board look at the tactics black's
threatening
and i mean oh my gosh so queen takes up
seventh check probably the only move and
he plays it
because you're giving up your rope but
you're getting that work back and this
doesn't look that bad for white it's not
good
but it looked a lot worse a few moves
ago 100
100 white really needs an h3 he needs to
get that king out
i know rookie eight for black because
then his native six check mm-hmm
okay so 85 looks like a good move knight
c3 maybe
drops the pawn and a4 this is looking
good for ali reza and look at knight g3
found so that if
you take my bishop might take yours and
two extra pawns but there's these double
pawns that are hard to push
okay nice new bishop v6 very good and if
you take maybe rook c6 and slot your
rook behind that pawn it's just bishop
g3 bishop g3 was winning on the spot
yeah oh that that was
needed to happen there although he is up
plenty of time so i think
there is a you know he's got this one
and artemia respectfully resigns
yeah and that's something we haven't
seen from almost any player i just want
to point that out like when someone has
seven seconds and that position is by no
means over you know the other person has
a little bit more than 10 15. we don't
usually see the resign but i completely
agree with it
yeah i think it makes sense six plus
minutes remaining so
it's a tied match i think that it's
easier for our teammate perhaps just to
resign because
he doesn't want to prolong the loss and
have to suffer and
well with the black pieces right now
look at this diagonal what's going on he
just plays d5
casually saying you take on e6 i take
back d5 is protected what are you
so casual like that's the the strongest
bishop on the board and he just opened
his rook
trapped in the corner and rook d2 is
swinging over as well
and versus by d4 he'll give up the
exchange and then he'll have a central
pawn
mass and then knight will go to e4 if
you take in the corner so that's why
already does not take it maybe pawn to
e4 can work out for white something like
uh oh knight d2
as well take on f6 knight d2 to e4 i
think white's position could actually
get quite good here
i agree the one thing that white has to
deal with is knight coming back because
we just saw knight c7 knight e6
things like that but where does the
knight go to there's actually nowhere
good
for it to reach that's right bishop e7
covering c5
is ultra important all right so
f4 that's a risky move just bishop
f8 rook to e7 coming but there's 1965
exactly if this gets to an end game i
like white that knight is going to end
up on d3
and that the wow what a sacrifice there
yeah that he trapped his queen but it's
not that bad
no it's pretty interesting actually rook
takes a four is a possibility so to
watch out for that because they're
rook f4 he plays it okay
and now rook h4 check is enough can you
take on h4 back oh i guess you can
i guess you can a g3 and rookie one oh
ricky wants like a mating attack
oh he goes here and then he's so close
though
he was really on e7 it's still hanging
oh my gosh he plays rookie seven he
finally moves there okay shoe check
take on f3 oh my goodness and the
bishop's still covering the knight on c7
that's unbelievable 96 okay you'll just
work again on f6
yeah that rook is just not going oh the
queen has august
and then the b-pawn and the g-punk go go
go go go go pre-move this
take on c5 i used to take an a4 that's
good take on c4 speaking all these
spawns yeah and then
i was almost stalemate oh my gosh he
made him
check me the bishop on h2 guarding the
knight on c7
that bishop did everything from d6 to
pin the pawn if
the lodge rook takes f4 and take on h4
take on g3 that bishop there was like
seven hanging rooks in that game and
then the irony was
white hung the queen once and the rook
took it
wow and let's see what's happening here
wait did these two play in the speed
chess championship
didn't they go down to the wire i i feel
like the answer has to be yes to that i
i'm getting the flashbacks i've seen a
match as good as this before
i feel like they went down to the very
last game but i i
i'm not too many matches have happened
but anyway we're in this one queen g7 is
mate so play bishop f6 to stop that mate
and he puts f6 instead which weakens the
light squares in front of his king
oh it really does and i was about to say
knight h4 was going to make you regret
that almost immediately queen g6 knight
f5 and
both threats knight h6 bishop f6 right
h6 yes indeed you can't take because the
bishop 6.
and i realized that i was mistaken it
was fedor save not artemia in that match
my apologies
but i you know this one is going our
terms with h4h586
yes you called it you called it and you
called it
here it comes so he could even allow the
queen to be captured on g6 to open the h
file he just
trades this way and is playing up a pawn
yeah he's he's just playing f3 g4 king
f2
and alert is fighting really well here
bishop d3 wow
that's a fork uh nice mover d2 you take
on a five twice you lose the d5 pawn
with check
right repeating moves times even by the
way there's no way our tamiya wants to
draw
no he's actually up like now he's not up
in time anymore it's going to be like
that it's going to be a see-saw
remember knight g6 bishop d6 yeah i
wonder what knight
is an e4 maybe e4 okay he doesn't go for
it
an exciting move so rook c2 bishop d3
rook c3 you get
out of this just barely yeah they
and then just barely's enough hang on e4
it's
almost made for both players uh the king
can slide to h3 safely
yep we can't go to f4 just rook f1 he's
got to go f2 if he wants to win
yep and i was i'm looking the clock i'm
looking to score i'm looking how much
times left in the match
there will be time for at least one more
game after this and there goes the h
pawn
push it push it you don't have time or
tamiya you gotta go
and ollie razor with a crazy good
defense oh we hung the bishop
trying to attack there and oh my gosh
are tamiya can he make it yeah the rooks
he should be able to do this
and if artemyev sees the match clock he
can win
already he can just play this out he can
just win the end
i this is one of the matches where i've
been so
intently following the games i didn't
even notice the match clock myself so
i would be impressed if either of these
guys knew what the heck was going on
yes because every game they've been
throwing haymakers at the other and
while that one went our 10 years away
ali reza needed that
and it looks like artemyev is going to
make his way through
to face a car nakamura because 55
seconds and counting down right now
and look look at that you've mentioned
55 the reason that he's playing
so fast is he saw the match clock i
think and he knows robert
basically the match is done he literally
has to pre-move the whole game he's
playing pretty well
he's playing well considering he's not
spending time you take on b5 this is
like a really good game by him what's
going on
yeah he's he has upped these queenside
passports push those things
yeah i just just play b5 like don't even
calculate it you may as well
and i know our tim is a respectful guy
but if he blunders something
you shouldn't resign buddy you should
keep it going yeah and look at queen b's
this is i mean a
really great game by all the races
beautiful game and bishop c5 then push
the
push to pawns a case of too little too
late bishop e2 nice to meet you
and oh my gosh oh no he resigned he
resigned oh
don't resign oh my gosh and he left in
time for one more game
he's trolling what are you doing
vladislav
why would you resign oh my he's
too respectful or he's just gonna do
some like
russian mic drop and just beat farouza
here and just be like
you know in soviet russia game beat you
oh my gosh i cannot believe that just
happened and
alireza actually needs to play a little
more slowly believe it or not
he needs to calm down because he's
probably on edge from that previous game
when he's moving against
every turn he he just needs to win this
game this is the final game regardless
so yeah you just need to win exactly
and he's in trouble now yes uh
sometimes knight c7 knight d6 something
or other f4 f5
i like what you're thinking it's just f4
f5 and the rooks get involved and
this is painful oh okay where
where is the goods where's the goods
take on
oh my look at him you just take the rook
he wants to keep keep that pin alive is
gonna pay off he takes queen d2 but hang
on knight e5 coming
wait a sec how do you end this game like
this is uh this is a constant knight e6
not g5 nice to me
96 step one yep
the king could take the knight on h3
barely escapes but maybe
oh man i want to play something like h5
and get it ready but it just doesn't
work
oh and the problem is he ca they're
probably some perpetual checks for black
he can't afford to draw he needs to win
this game it's about even the clock i
think i like black's position because
knight g4 knight e3
oh oh that's a big fork you can't stop
it yep
that's you got to move fast here if
you're artemium and that's pre-moved by
ali reza he knows what he needs to do
here a4 though keeping the pieces out e4
e4 you gotta put it quickly okay king
goes somewhere rook b5 good move
yep well artemis played pretty well
considering he's
allowed all this but he's oh mouse slip
and that's the game and that's a tight
match
that is a tied match which means
we are going to overtime and what does
the tie break look like
it is sudden death the higher seed
that is alireza farouja gets the white
pieces
if either side wins the game the match
is over if it's a draw they switch
colors
they repeat until somebody wins so
vladislav artemyev
i've said this previously one of the
nicest people
in the world of chess he was too nice
not being nice does not win you bullet
chess championships
no no nice guys finished last robert
that
that is so unfortunate he had the match
he deserved the match
he kept playing on and resigned with
eight seconds on the match clock
you know what credit to ferugia he said
look if you're gonna make a mistake like
that i'm going to make it count
he wins the game off a mouse slip but he
did have the extra piece and was up on
time
so he was definitely about to win that
and now we're about to get
into a bullet game and what an intense
format robert it's just
where if you win and you go home that's
it
i just can't believe it i'm trying to
think about this alireza is probably
jittery
because he was playing on pure
adrenaline those last two games right so
he's nervous he needs to calm down
because now it's anybody's contest
for artemyev for no better word
you're pissed off like you are winning
the match and i wonder if
anybody's told him that he could have
won had he just not resigned i hope no
i hope the answer is no and i hope that
he can just put aside those two straight
losses
and he can just play the next game just
one more game at a time he's been doing
well with the black pieces these gurgaon
needs these systems
they've been playing to his favor and
ali reza is back in his chair which
means we are about to have
the tie break this is exciting as it
gets
yeah strap in guys because this one
bullet game is gonna
if you blink you might miss it wow and
this
this game one game for all the marvels
they draw we get another one but
what does alireza ferrugia going to do
he has the white pieces will he go back
to what he's been playing
i don't know because it feels like
artemium hasn't figured out but
already has the momentum right now yeah
he certainly does
he is i mean he was so dejected after
the two-game lead opened up because he
knew that the match was over he saw the
match clock but it just never occurred
to his opponent
and hey if you're going to get these
chances hit in life robert you got to
make them count if you're ali reza
and we usually can't criticize super
grandmasters too much over the board so
at least they've given us an opportunity
to
criticize some of their actions off of
it and a very respectful
thing but you can't do that with mere
seconds left in the match talk the timer
ticking down
that is a missed opportunity for
vladislav artemyev
100 no way to sugarcoat it um but
nevertheless vladislav artemyev has just
as much chance as ali reza to win this
game here
doesn't matter what he's done in the
past hopefully he doesn't know about it
and he's just focused on this game and
here we go we get a locked up king side
the pawn march forward to the h file to
trade
trade on g6 at some point but black
doesn't mind that because that king side
is locked up and
now we get this king's indian style a4
a5
on your way for white yeah knight b3 or
knight d3 and then a4
a5 is going to happen you want to loosen
up b6 go for c5 afterwards meanwhile
black
opposite side of the board same idea
love that move c5 the bishop was trapped
now the bishop is still trapped so he
takes it off the board castles kingside
the king is safe on g8 how about that
king in the center love the position for
black
g4 i'm waiting for that move to happen
but white's saying look
queen takes d6 huge threat which is why
knight f7 was necessary
and there goes g4 maybe even a g3 he
holds off on that because he can take on
f3
queen g3 check he keeps the tension so
that he can do it at the right time that
benefits his
chances here and that i mean that bishop
takes knight that's a tough decision
to to make there and once again we see
that alvarez takes on g4 but the knight
is quickly taking back on g4
so rookie eight queen d7 there's rookie
seven
after that but okay yeah i guess the
queen trapped on the
oh queen d5 you barely escape but then
there's g4
and it does not look good no it does not
that bishop could get in the game like
bishop h6 pawn f3 something like that
is what you want but how to break open
the position
i have no idea what's going on but all i
know is ali reza's position has
definitely improved in last couple moves
hey watch out for some kind of rook g
file rook g8 because there are no pieces
covered yes rook g
file yeah can't do it because of the
pawn f4
he was hanging he took you take on g2
take it all
three then the rookie bishop that's a
good move
it's a great move queen g5 is great
better quick quick takes d2
yep has to be it and bishop takes and
then they're working up on time
okay but he's not moving that quickly he
has to move fast h5 or gate seven
ferrugia is just sending the speed right
now but
he should be outmatched here h2 put it
on a safe square
oh oh he he took the pawn he timed that
perfectly
you cannot pre when the pawns on h2 you
don't pre-move the next two moves you
play rookie seven rook g1 and then you
pre-move
and artemia looks like he's going down
here he is just getting ruthlessly
flagged he cannot take that pawn
no he can't and he loses on time and all
the reason for rusev goes through
wow and look at that little fist pump
there he cannot believe it
he's just finally breathing for the
first time in about
three games and look at that smile from
the teenager
he is just lucky to be alive he knows it
takes the swing of his water and
for vladislav of i mean it's just all
sinking in right now
well yeah because not only did he not
win the match
from what should have been running out
the clock just a little bit more
but he lost the match from having his
clock run out
it's pretty bad karma all around what a
game he played in this final one like he
was playing a masterful game
where he was winning over the board and
he was at least
even on the clock so something just went
wrong down the stretch for artemyev
in his decision making to resign in his
this last game here and that decision
rook takes h2 by our 10 excuse me by
alireza furuja
that won him this match it wasn't even
the resignation earlier he was losing in
this game
but he took on h2 anticipating a
pre-move and he was able to escape with
that decision
yeah it's exactly what happened there
and obviously i mean we just
feel for artemiev such a deserving
player in this match but
you can't take any way anything away
from alyreza because he played the match
as it's supposed to be played
you definitely flagged this game that he
just did and
it's up to his opponent whether he
resigned that last game nothing that ali
reza could control
so i mean ali reza stuck in there and
made it count he obviously took
advantage of that chance but robert what
a finish here what a thrilling finish to
this day of chess yeah he could only
control so much as things were getting
out of control
we're gonna try to get things in order
we're gonna take a quick break and when
in return we'll be joined
by the winner of this match alirezafruga
you will want to hear his thoughts so
stay tuned for more
from the bullet chess championship
presented by sig
[Music]
and welcome back everyone we are joined
by grand master ali reza ferrugia
victorious after a match that ali reza
let's be fair at some point
did you think that it was just all over
and mathematically you had no chance to
come back
i uh before the last game right the last
game that i won i checked the
the timer and i i thought that if i
remove all the moves i have
i have chances so that is what happened
exactly so
yeah there is isn't it kind of funny
that you played maybe your best game
when you pre-moved all the moves right
yeah really good game right yeah yeah of
course no
at that moment i thought i'm going to
lose but yeah okay maybe the pressure
was off so maybe that
also helped legion so yeah yeah and
obviously you notice the the difference
that uh artemia probably
wasn't as aware of the match clock as
you because he resigned in a position
where
if he had obviously he you were winning
the game but
yeah if he had just not resigned that's
a win for artemyev
yeah he could have played right yeah
yeah but i don't think he was aware so
obviously paying attention
to the match clock what you were doing
was was obviously uh pretty important
yeah it was only five seconds right yeah
so it was very close
yeah well i mean the whole match was
closed through and through what do you
think it was about vladisoft's style or
the way he was playing
that was giving you such difficulty yeah
it was it was very interesting the
openings i think mostly it was in his
style i couldn't get my openings exactly
the way
i wanted so that was really helpful for
him and
i think in general he's a great led
player he's rated
3 200 right so he's not like
um other guys like he does he doesn't
train he's always at the top
in titled arnold's or all the
tournaments so he's
very experienced i think so yeah that's
that's a great point
um yeah early on in the match ali reza
maybe some bad memories sorry to bring
them up but
right it felt like you you just weren't
even in the match and you had to resign
that game in like 30
seconds yeah felt like it was a slow
start for you no it
it was very similar to my match against
fedocif right
so it was like very close at the end but
the tiger the sudden this i lost that
game but here i won
so that was the only difference and yeah
the first games i have to
be more focused because um i was playing
just
the moves like without i was not
carrying much
so maybe next time i have to be more
focused yeah well
next time is tomorrow and you play
against hikaru nakamura so
well what are you going to do to prepare
yourself for that match against
obviously one of the absolute best
bullet players on the planet right so
three times i think
two times i played icaru in final of
bullet championship i lost maybe this
time
same final maybe i have some better
chances
i i also wanted to ask you ali reza
about maybe
maybe the move that secured the whole
match for you the dirty move rook takes
right yeah of course yeah yeah what
about that one that one was beautiful
it was very important then to take on h2
like i was thinking about it like
five moves before when should i take on
h2 i think
after king geforce is like the he
doesn't think about rookie still because
he needs three moves to get his rook on
g1 and then
i take on h2 so it's very interesting uh
the experience helped somewhere finally
yeah
so you were saying that even a couple
moves before that you were thinking
about when right yeah
yeah yeah yeah you see
that's what they do these days robert
they're right they're calculating
dirty moves yeah
well alireza you seem all smiles right
now i mean that must be just
a sigh of relief there after the match
turned in your favor down the stretch
you played amazingly well
so congratulations to you thank you so
much get on with your night we'll see
you tomorrow buddy
thanks guys thank you take care and that
was alireza farouza super grand
master making his way to the semi-finals
where he'll play against hikaru nakamura
that is a match up
that has everybody salivating in
anticipation
and amana normally puts you on the spot
but this time i will not we have our top
four in place
let's just enjoy what we just saw
because that really
was an absolutely brilliant match and
you know we're not allowed we can't end
our show without the uh
our lovely game of the day our trade of
the day
there and we know what it was yeah we
got to show it
and just talked what a decision
by alireza to take on h2 he said he
thought about this moves in advance
when to capture and he does it probably
way before artemyev could have suspected
it
yeah and the thing about the this trade
of the day
this important moment here is that uh
obviously black
is about to either play rook g7 rook g1
or walk the king all the way up the
board so that's
many many moves away if you choose the
king what i was saying was that usually
as black
you do not pre-move for these two moves
and then you wait and see the response
and then you pre-move the rest of the
game
once you establish whether you're
getting a queen or not vlad maybe just a
little bit lack of experience
he decides to use the king that's a lot
of moves and
wow look at this i mean rook takes h2 he
times it with the pre-move
king g4 and he gets away with murder
there robert
yeah you're right and richie said rook
g1 that would have been the way to go
just quicker than bishop wanted for
cover the pawn
unfortunately for artemia if things just
did not go his way down the stretch
this was no exception so ali raza fruja
he earns his spot in the semifinals
maybe he shouldn't even had a chance
maybe artemis should not resign he did
that ends that and so we move to our top
four
players by seed making the way the
semi-finals this is not
march madness in terms of the college
men's college basketball tournament
no it is not this is the top four moving
on in the bullet chess championship
presented by sig so amman
how do we sum up the day we just had
here
incredible uh i mean first of all truly
truly exciting
uh i was really thrilled that at least
we had a couple very close matches today
hey when hikaru is playing you can never
be guaranteed a close match
he is just too strong sometimes and he
displayed that today
but the the tang match and this ferrugia
match i don't think tang or faruja at
some point in both of their matches
thought they had any chance of
qualifying and yet they both ended up so
that just paints the story
that just tells the tale of what today
was in a nutshell robert
tons of exciting tactical chess and the
fact that the top four
bullet players are moving on in the
competition just makes me even more
excited for
tomorrow absolutely and one storyline
that we should i guess talk about is
donya didn't play today and of course
that was unfortunate that
uh eric could not take part but i guess
fortunately for donna he moves to
semifinals but he doesn't get that
experience those
clock ticking down nerve-wracking
moments he doesn't have that
and so perhaps for tang who was down
five to one that could play to his
benefit so if
diane does get a lead early in the match
tang knows he's not out of it
yeah that's 100 true and i think just
getting used to playing
these tough players in a non-stream
format money on the line
i think it's worth the warm up so you'll
constantly hear top players like
sort of almost being annoyed at getting
seated in because yeah they don't get to
get that warm up like everyone else
absolutely true partner and let's remind
everybody of what time they should be
here tomorrow
the times have changed because today was
titled tuesday that changed the start
time
tomorrow will be the semis and finals
beginning at 9 00 a.m pacific time
that's noon in new york if you're in
europe and elsewhere you can do the
conversion but
9 a.m pacific tomorrow and of course we
have the all-star match up
noon pacific on thursday amman
it's been another great show with you we
were on the edge of our seats jumping
out of our seats
at some moments it was probably the best
day thus far and it's
likely only going to get better tomorrow
as we get the top four in the semis
well that's what the bullet chest
championship bracket does you know it
narrows it down to an eventual winner
and
i think that the hype it makes sense
that it gets better day by day as we
slowly do find the strongest players in
the competition
and people get knocked out so we're
constantly left with the best of the
best and we have some
seriously heavyweight bullet matches
coming for you guys tomorrow so
you absolutely do not want to miss that
i'm really really looking forward to
tomorrow's commentary
for sure and well while we don't enjoy
it we must say goodbye now thank you to
everybody
who's tuned in our great audience all of
our moderators the entire chat
our producers everyone working behind
the scenes to make this possible
thank you for watching the bullet chest
championship presented by sag be tuned
in tomorrow for more from chess.com from
this bullet chess championship
[Music]
you